I heard this story people were going
nuts everybody's all Angry on Twitter
James Madison was he the fourth
president I think he's got this Crystal
flute it's like a legendary Crystal
flute it was in possession of the
Library of Congress who reached out to
lizzo uh for those she's a she's a very
famous musician and she twerked on stage
while playing it thus fulfilling the
prophecy signaling the end of the
American Empire no uh but a lot of
people are making jokes about how like
American history is now a joke a
spectacle signifying that like
you know we've outlived our history I
guess we've outlived uh the I guess I
guess the word is Traditions or you know
the historical value is just gone it's
become spectacle and uh I just thought
it was funny I thought I thought I
thought it was funny because you know
I'm not trying to be mean to Liz or
anything but she's like this very large
morbidly obese woman playing this like
legendary historical flute on stage and
it just kind of feels inappropriate for
anyone you know and notice respect to
lizzo but like for anyone to like do
that but it is what it is so we'll talk
about that story because I guess
everybody's laughing about it but we got
another story that's really depressing
CNN had this great headline and it's and
it said Joe Biden calls out to deceased
a congresswoman at a conference
and it's it was just it was sad because
uh I mean this woman lost her life uh
a month ago Joe Biden's asking where she
is and he paid tribute to her personally
so the dude's brain is just rotted to
the core or he didn't actually bother
when she died you know pick one either
way it's just brutal so we'll talk about
that plus there's a whole bunch of other
stories I guess before we get started my
friends head over to timcast.com become
a member to support our work we have a
members only uncensored show coming up
tonight at 11 PM and uh you're also
supporting our journalists people like
Christopher Bertman who wrote the story
about lizzo twerking while playing James
Madison Madison's flute and our other
reporters who are working every day we
had a great video I don't know if you
saw it uh elad went on the ground to a
fetterman rally and asked people if they
what they thought about John fetterman
chasing after an innocent black man with
a shotgun because he thought he was
shooting guns or something like that and
it's remarkable to see these people just
say outright like they don't care that
he did it and he even asks one person
like there's there's a racial Reckoning
happening don't you think something here
maybe Ben like well I don't believe you
anyway so and it just goes to show that
the state of politics in this country
but if you want to support that stuff it
is 100 membership supported so if you
like the field reporting you like the
the written articles come become a
member at timcast.com and also don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about all of this is
Richie McGinnis
how are we doing folks who are you I am
Richard McGinnis I am actually now no
longer the video director of The Daily
Caller I am an independent Gonzo
journalist you can look that up I know
it's not a phrase that's used often
these days uh that's Richie r-i-c-h-i-e
McGinnis twice two ends two s's falsely
defamed by I think the New York Times I
think I'm just just I think I'm just
defamed generally at this point but and
we were we were tweeting because you
wrote an op-ed for Newsweek about Kyle
Rittenhouse and then Jack besobic uh
criticized you for it uh Jack is
unfortunately not here to uh um to
defend his positions but he had he had
he had obligations but you know I
respect Jack's position I respect
everybody's position
um
I think that's the point of an open
discourse and that's one of the reasons
why you know I put my personal account
out there as opposed to the account that
came out in court because I think that
the emotional experience and I know that
that's a big trigger word uh right there
but that's different from
the actual
undeniable truth of what the law is the
way human experiences something is
different from that so uh also Ian is
not with us tonight unfortunately there
is a uh he's just chilling but he might
pop in at some other point but we do
have thanks to Hurricane Ian don't walk
run Productions hello everybody hanging
out
thank you uh I'm I'm Andrew from don't
walk run Productions you can find me on
YouTube at uh just type in don't walk
run or don't walk run at Twitter uh I
would like to thank uh our amazing host
here Tim Paul for and and uh the gang
for uh letting me be a refugee uh so
thank you very much and I just want to
say hi to everybody in Florida and just
you know hope you guys are we like to
say we like to say legal Asylum
it was either here or Martha's Vineyard
and uh I think I think I probably had a
better chance here so I yeah I didn't
want to be shipped to like a joint Air
Force Base up in Massachusetts so uh I'm
just staying in a just staying in a
hotel waiting waiting to get back you
know we we take in refugees you know we
we want to do right and so we we uh we
we gave uh we got a hotel I think you
know yeah just don't try and come here
if you're uh yeah without you let it let
him know ahead of time but if you show
up you'll get a shot probably we also
have the uh the milk Merchant yeah I
don't know how I feel about this guy
staying around here but uh that's a
separate topic anyway it's time for me
to be professional I wanted to apologize
for my gags and Goofs it was a little
distracting with my bazangas out to
talking about World War III I definitely
I think I milked that bit to the last
drop and plus my shirts were being
ruined the wonderful amazing shirts that
you could get on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com like this one
that's says it's not the news it's an
establishment press release which you
could exclusively get on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do I'm here thanks so much I I just want
to add too quite often it's not the news
quite literally someone will send a
press release to a news outlet and
they'll just reword it and publish it
yep all the time and it's just literally
PR for the richest people in the world
yeah and you can get those shirts in
long sleeve and short sleeves just
remember that thank you okay it's you
know just it's cold in the studio Yeah
Tim did turn down the turn down the
temperature just to get those that's
true the nips popping yeah well of
course of course you've got to make the
big bucks we know it makes money
it's true we do and I think that tonight
would have been the perfect opportunity
to say that Ian is busy because he's
down in Florida obviously that's
obviously that's not the case I've heard
that 21 waffle houses are closed right
now thoughts and prayers to Florida
that's a very bad sign very excited to
hear we have to talk about tonight let's
get going if Tim can see so the first
story we have here from timcast.com
lizzo twerks while playing James
Madison's flute at DC concert and uh and
that's it you know one of the uh
earliest Presidents had a crystal Flute
from 1813 and the Library of Congress
brought that on stage to this woman so
that she could uh toot her flute and
twerk and something something about this
just it's a it's a it's a it's a circus
it's a spectacle it is I don't know what
the right word is for it but it seems
unserious like we've become a very
unserious people as a waste of taxpayer
dollars well yeah yeah but what I mean
is you know we used to be like we're
going to the Moon people not because we
want to but because we have to or
whatever I don't know the quote was but
it was like you look back on history and
we see these very serious things
everything was a large matter of a
matter of consequence you've got Wars
you've got civil rights you've got all
of this huge historical stuff happening
and I look back on that I'm like either
the country is is completely Fallen
apart because we have no serious culture
we're permanently children you know good
times make weak men or it never existed
in the first place and we just
romanticize the past so so you're
telling me James Madison wasn't twerking
and playing his flute at the same time
that's what he would do yeah he would go
up on stage and he would you know twerk
that was very big in the late 70s yeah I
thought I thought what she did was very
bold and brave bold uh very bold uh and
you know the cloth stuck up her uh took
us was definitely an added uh artistic
expression that I think we have to fully
support because it's again something
that is uh is is nice now so uh so I
fully support it here's here's lizzo
tweeting nobody has ever heard this
famous Crystal flute before now you have
I'm the first and only person to ever
play this presidential 200 year old
Crystal flute thank you Library of
Congress you know I can appreciate this
she's very happy to be uh uh you know
playing this but there's something about
it that to me it's just kind of like
I don't think disrespectful is the right
word but is is desecration yeah that's a
creation of historical artifacts of
History it's a really neat piece of
History it's beautiful and she just no
she upped the value now you know lizzo
played James Madison's flute like her
buttocks of flailing up and down making
the clap noise adds value to this
historical thing and now when we think
of James Madison's fluke we think of the
wonderful
booty of Miss lizzo which uh I think
only makes it that much better
the first time
this reminds me of like idiocracy and
Wally
like the look of shock and excitement on
her face
[Applause]
I think that comment was perfect right
there I just I just kind of feel like
you know we're we're on the verge of
World War III and Vladimir Putin's
sitting back in his chair and he's
watching this and he's like yeah it's
all over
you know what I mean you don't
understand the major accomplishment that
this was yes thank you and finally
someone sees it like I do this is this
is Americana personified right in our
reality I mean what else do you need to
to see to understand that this is this
is America at its best right now I think
oh sorry go ahead no I was gonna say I
think the Chinese Engineers of tick tock
are the ones who are sitting back
laughing because if you're asking
yourself what does our culture pay
attention to well
that's what tick tock tick tock tick
tock culture will get you right there oh
man and and these Tick Tock videos they
pop up on Instagram too and I look at
them and I'm like okay people are being
programmed with this stuff like have you
seen these videos there's a lot of memes
and they play songs and they all do the
exact same thing and it's like
is degenerate the right word you know
depraved yeah yeah it's working on
people basic impulse impulses and when
you look at Chinese Tick Tock and their
algorithm and you compare it to the
American Tick Tock and what is shown to
our children here that it's captivating
so much of their attention span that
YouTube is trying to copy every uh thing
that Tick Tock is right now you see a
huge difference what is represented to
the children of China that are limited
on the platform only to I believe an
hour or two hours per day they're shown
educational content they're shown
content that that informs them about
things that about their culture about
their society about things that they
could be doing art uh math science all
of that is prioritized here twerking
sexuality degeneracy idiocy hurting
people making fun of people uh and
normalizing obesity normalizing uh
castration normalizing some of the most
craziest ideas which some people would
hint at is a form of fifth generational
Warfare with people being brainwashed
and doing things that essentially hurt
them their families their communities
and eventually the country and I think
this needs to be understood when it
comes to seeing the algorithm and its
larger impacts on society do you guys
ever take the um moral foundations test
you know that you know that one it's
based on Jonathan Heights research there
are six moral foundations you guys know
you know another one uh liberals have
only two
conservatives have all six and
Libertarians only have one of course
Libertarians and it's liberty everything
else yeah it's just Liberty so like well
lizzo's free to do this they ask
questions
um to find out where your moral
foundations are I usually get what are
this it says like left liberal but I've
I have a decent balance uh across the
board but I have really high Liberty and
then I have really high like fairness
liberals only have care and fairness as
their moral foundations they have no uh
loyalty like sanctity Purity or whatever
the other ones are and then they have
very low Liberty on average and then
Libertarians they just don't care about
anything but Liberty so the questions
they ask you
it'll be like on there's a scale where
it's like how okay are you with this
scenario and one of them would be one of
them is uh Janet is cleaning her attic
when she comes across an old war
memorial flag from her grandfather's
time in in a service and she picks it up
and uses a washcloth to scrub the floors
are you okay with this liberals tend to
say yeah who cares Libertarians tend to
say yeah who cares conservatives tend to
say this is not okay so in that regard I
actually say yeah absolutely not okay I
think for me it's like it's important to
recognize the past so that we can learn
from it understand it and improve moving
forward but when I see something like
this I don't I don't feel like Rage or
disgust I just kind of I kind of feel
like yeah we're going down we're going
downhill because there's there's a
certain amount of respect you would have
for objects and artifacts and things
that represent the successes and and the
failures of humanity and for this
spectacle of this big you know what's
the right word bodacious Bodacious yes
sure Luke but look look I'm not trying
to be mean to to lizzo because you know
I'm fairly I got that libertarian Spike
but what I see here is American history
being mocked essentially by a morbidly
obese woman on stage as a spectacle as a
gag as a joke totally disrespecting what
it is what it represents what it's
supposed to be and as Luke was saying
it's it's the normalization all of all
of these really negative traits that
we're supposed to be okay with I look at
this and I feel like it's idiocracy I
feel like it's Wally you know in Wally
everybody's morbidly obese they have no
bone density anymore that's that's not
the kind of place we want to go we don't
want to go into some future where
everyone's like He-Man ripped and like
it's sparred or anything like that but
the very least we can be like hey you
know we're gonna respect the the relics
of our past so we can understand it this
to me is just like taking a dump on the
American flag you know do you think that
people would have said the same thing in
the late 1960s like you know
conservatives at the time would have
said America's going down the toilet
this is it it's over like because
America does to a certain extent
oscillate between conservative and no
for sure culture right and I've thought
about that so I decided you know what
this could just be our generation's
conflict so I asked a bunch of older
people who were around back then they
said certainly not
they said it's never been this bad so
maybe we're just oscillating downwards I
think we are I went to I went to an
antique shop it's amazing uh I got a
photo I got books uh it's the
photographic history of the Civil War
it's his collection it's from 1913 I
think it's very expensive and it's
amazing you opened up and there's
pictures from like Civil War
battlefields and stuff and I asked this
guy was in his 60s have have you ever
seen it this bad and he says no
absolutely not now granted in the 60s he
was you know that's around the time he
was born uh he was he was a small child
but I've asked a bunch of older people
too because uh people we've had on the
show we've had a lot of people on the
show who are like in their 70s and older
and they all say the same thing it has
never been this bad so I have to wonder
you know well here's maybe just one
question here
do you also think that the power of
information and technology and the way
in which ideas can basically go between
groups of people go between countries in
a way that they never could before like
to at a certain point the top is going
to blow off and people will awaken to
the fact that they've been you know
controlled in these paradigms like what
we're looking at right there and
everybody's celebrating you know you
know what you know what I wonder is
there seems to be
independent thinkers and dependent
thinkers and I wonder what the Catalyst
for that is why is it that some people
want to live in The Matrix and some
people don't is this something inherent
to an individual down to their core
their soul or is it a learned behavior
or something that could at least be
snapped out of I certainly think humans
are uh amorphous to the point where
anyone can be red pilled anyone can be
woke it doesn't matter where you're from
but I wonder if there's a tendency due
to something you know inherent I'm not
saying I know for sure I'm wondering I
guess I think that that battle happens
has happened since America was accepted
it's between the Puritans who settled
you know in the mass Bay colonies wrote
the first laws in the United States like
one of the first laws written in the
United States was you can't beat your
wife with a stick any thicker than your
thumb I don't think that's true yes it
is
let's look it up I think that's a
microphone no it's it's literally like
there are like 12 laws that were written
in the mass Bay colonies and that's one
of them
let's check it out anyways there's then
there were the hillbillies who also came
and they conquered the frontier and
they're like I'm not going to listen to
your laws I'm not going to listen to
that I think to a certain extent America
is unique in that we have those two
cultures kind of battling it out
uh let's see
English jurist Sir William Blackstone
wrote in the commentaries of the laws of
England an old law that wants moderate
beatings by husbands but he did not
mention thumbs yeah I'm pretty sure
that's apocryphal
so when you search for this you get rule
of thumb and they say that the rule of
thumb is not a real thing um yeah I'm
talking about beating your wife with a
stick thicker than your thumb but that's
where they that's where that comes from
so well that's what people are saying it
it's based on you know that the rule of
thumb is about beating your wife when
it's actually so there's a courtroom in
1824 that asserted this
wait uh a ruling in Mississippi stated
the man was entitled to enforce domestic
discipline by striking his wife with a
whip or stick no wider than the judge's
Thumb in a later case in 1868 the
defendant was found to have struck his
wife with a switch with the size of his
fingers the judge found the man not
guilty due to the switch being smaller
than the thumb so I don't know man you
don't don't beat your wife it's not cool
well clearly clearly that was aside from
this point
yeah well I don't think this is my I
think this is my take on the whole as a
situation I don't think it's that deep
I don't first of all did anybody in this
room know the existence of that flute
before today no no and it's very cool
what okay James Madison apparently never
played it so it was probably just given
to him like somebody made it makes it
worse we don't know the historical
significance of this flu other than
James Madison probably got it during his
presidency
lizzo absolutely did not know about that
flu she had a concert there somebody in
the National Archives is probably like I
really like this and we have this stupid
flute that nobody's played and it it's
like let me let me answer it's like
Pixar it's like Pixar okay John Lasseter
used to have like a in his office he
used to have all the Pixar toys and then
little kids would want to touch him and
he's like no no no don't touch him and
he's like wait a minute their toys kids
should be allowed to play them and the
National Archives is probably the same
thing like that flute needs to be played
right so that makes it worse right if
you if you had an original sealed Han
Solo action figure mint condition and
then someone was like let's tear it open
and play with it dude destroy the value
of it the fact that it's preserved is
what makes it valuable but if you're
George Lucas who cares like you're just
like sure kid go play with right this is
a this is the property of the American
public that was never played before was
a historical artifact was handed off to
some Entertainer to play on stage and
that's why I said desecration
it's it's it's no longer this pristine
Crystal flute that was ornamental it is
now a gag prop for for a stage show well
it's not like she pooped on an American
flag I mean she just like played a flute
for five seconds I mean it's I I
wouldn't necessarily call it desecration
I would say the whole situation is like
I'm not I'm trying I'm not trying to say
that it's like akin to like pissing on a
grave or anything but like it has
fundamentally altered what that object
was and I just think what we see
consistently is this this idea that
these people uh you know typically on
the left care absolutely nothing for
this country they call it historically
racist they crap all over it and it's
all hypocrisy they're more than happy to
say defund the police but then call the
police on people they don't like they're
more than happy to to all laugh and
cheer and scream 16 19 project but then
be like we get to play with this
historical artifact it's just
what I see is you can certainly look to
the Past in your country and and and say
hey there were bad things and we want to
do away with those but I think you
absolutely have to respect you know the
beginnings of where you come from and
the history of your country I think look
what it comes down to is the reverence
for this country is is just flushed on
the toilet and this is this may just be
a grain of sand in the Heap but this is
like a big show where they pulled from
the archives from the Library of
Congress and brought it on stage to make
some spectacle out of I'm not saying
it's the apocalypse but it's not I'm not
like significant either the actual flute
like you know we don't we don't know
what it's about like who gave it to him
like why was it given it why was it made
I don't think that's relevant
like I've got I've got a coin uh I've
got I've got a coin from Athens you know
that I got at a shop I don't know who
spend it I don't know why it was for a
you know a minted no idea all I know is
that it exists it's it's it's evidence
of the civilization that existed it's
it's a reminder of these things I was
also uh I got this for Sheamus it was a
coin used by Saint Casper that uh well
they they alleged it was it was one of
the same coins that were were minted
around the same time that was given to
St Casper was one of the wise men it may
have been used by him we don't know for
sure but this was the the these were the
ones minted in this area where they
believe you came from and that's a
representation of something valuable
using it as currency is meaningless but
to like to take these items and treat
them like just spectacles and toys or
gag shows I think is is look no no one
desecration I think is like a signal of
the Apocalypse that's the gag I put in
the title of this video I just think
that this is just another sign of the
decay of the core and the soul of this
country
what do you people think vote number one
if you vote for the Decay vote number
two if this is the same accident let me
know down in the chat room right now
I'll give you this Andrew from CNN Biden
asks if deceased congresswoman is
present at White House food and security
conference does this do it for you is
this a more apocalyptic the president
who a month ago paid tribute to a
congressman who died seemingly
forgetting he did that a month later
calls out to her and says is she here
where is she I guess she's not here I
guess not huh just a week and a half ago
he was on 60 Minutes and he asked him if
he was mentally and physically fit to
serve office and he's like oh I'm oh I'm
focused oh I'm focused and then two
weeks later you know he's he's uh he's
like oh where's the dead congresswoman
yeah I mean oh my God like come on
that's it he's undermining his own
argument oh yeah I'm oh I'm I'm in good
shape I'm in good shape I'm 80. you know
it's it this isn't he all he may almost
total clown world he may be the only
person who doesn't realize I mean that's
how
brain Decay works you know you're not
aware you don't have any nerve endings
in your brain you don't feel any pain
from it so I don't think we should be
asking him if he has brain Decay that's
not how it usually you don't ask a
person with dementia if they have
dementia but everybody else around him
is is like their his yes man he has two
metal stints inside of his head holding
back major major uh what is it aneurysms
um so he is not in good health but he
has his finger on the button to
literally blow up the world 20 times
over he could do it any moment anytime
according to the official story of how
the government actually runs and how the
president is in charge and the
commander-in-chief which I question and
I think his his decline perfectly shows
what I think is what is happening behind
the scenes of just the front guy that
they're pushing forward to blame for the
acceleration of the great reset let's
put him up forward let's blame
everything on this cognitive decline
meanwhile the richest most Sinister
people behind the scenes are grabbing up
everything for themselves and pushing
them most absurd policies that no
president would ever want to be known
for so but I want to I want to give a
shout out to CNN because
um you know I I this headline is amazing
Biden asks if deceased congresswoman is
present at White House food in security
conference they could have spun that A
Million Ways well they did CNN did yeah
they did there was uh there was actually
let me find it it was an other
uh article too let me give me one second
I just like I like I like how they
framed it when Kareem Jean-Pierre was
asked she was like well clearly uh to
Joe she was top of top of mind she was
off top of mind and I'm like what is she
saying what does that mean Joe Biden
called out to a woman who is no longer
living and then asked if she was here
and said I guess she's not it's like bro
do you remember that you paid tribute to
her like you wrote a letter I guess he
didn't write the letter but totally
forgotten don't you think that that
going back to what we were saying
earlier you know is there a certain
breaking point at which people wake up
don't you think any sentient human being
saw that would be like yo that's BS
person of the White House is literally
lying in front of me oh but but it's
been happening look come on Russia gate
if you still believe this stuff just I'm
I'm that's why I'm saying is a point you
know there's a um we talked about this a
bunch of times in the past when we get
into our weird and wild Shenanigans
shows but I was like there's some
religious Theory or a theory isn't the
right word this idea that there's a
finite number of Souls and that some
people are born without a soul because
let's say there's only a billion Souls
available so when more people are being
born there's people who don't have any
Souls because there's not enough of them
I'm not saying I believe that but that's
a you know conversation we had the
argument then becomes if only that means
one in seven people are just mindlessly
drifting about without any sentient
function you know what I mean
like dude at what point do we say
someone is cognitively deficient if they
believe this stuff you know what I mean
that's a I mean that's a good you find
the article it's a question of what
reality is and how it's being fabricated
yeah uh the the article is Joe Biden's
latest gaffe plays right into
Republicans Republicans pounds all right
was that an opinion piece though uh it's
under CNN politics so I mean it's it's
announced I guess but this this one's
like their actual news article and they
just outright say it he asks if deceased
congressman is present like
I feel like that's a very harsh framing
it's hard to ignore it though it's hard
it's it's hard for a news organization
to actually spin that and go like like
NPR somebody pointed out that NPR did a
a piece on the event that he did and
didn't mention the the gaffe at all how
much do you want to bet he really thinks
kamala's the president
you know how he's like called her
president several times yes like they
just he look he was in the basement the
whole time the campaign was going on for
all we know they came downstairs and
said congratulations you're your VP
again he was like oh oh great who's
President Kamal is like oh all right
he's called Doug emhoff the first lady
I'm not I'm not kidding I'm not even
making a joke it's it's true story I
kind of feel like you know at what point
do we just sit back light up a cigar and
and you know ride the the gravity bomb
down I thought that's what we're doing
yeah yeah since January 20th I will say
though having my dad uh suffer from
degenerative brain disease over the
course of a number of years it's
interesting because kind of your core
nature comes out and like all the core
habits you know like needed a cup of
coffee like you you stick to the things
that you really know that you can rely
on every day your routines but for him
it was like the opposite it was like he
was so unwilling to give up his
independence that any time that you try
to help him with anything you know he'd
be smacking you away I think Joe Biden
was just complicit in this stupid game
from the beginning and so now it's just
like
It's Just Happening easier you know you
just just kind of cruises yeah people
were saying on Twitter that this is was
it sundowning but it's getting worse if
it's to the point where like it was a
month ago that he sent out a letter
being like tribute to walorski's family
and I think that's our last name Rick
rollerski and he doesn't even remember
that it's just like come on dude that's
it's worse it gets worse they actually
had a tribute to her at the event yeah
so here he's coming out to speak this
event that was actually going to do a
memorial tribute to her and he asks if
she's in the audience like this might
not be dementia this might be something
substantially worse than that like it's
one thing that your brain stops working
you're forgetting things and you're
confused it's another thing when you're
like putting Concepts together that
shouldn't exist like we're paying
tribute to this woman who died is she
here sitting in the audience somewhere
like yeah there's no way he's in charge
he had major brain surgery a number of
times being the president of the United
States is an extremely exhausting
stressful job that many presidents age
severely during their time in office you
look at the presidents uh maybe you know
people make arguments against Donald
Trump but you look at Obama you look at
Clinton you look at Bush they look like
totally different human beings before
they came into office and after they
came into office as years off of their
life have been taken away there is no
way he is slaving away there's no way
he's at that desk making the decisions
he's not in charge he's not calling the
shots the bigger question that people
need to be asking themselves is when
he's not there he's checked out he can't
even make coherent sentences who's
really in charge that's the question
that a lot of people should be asking
themselves can we give a round of
applause to the onion for this I already
did it I love to bring this article up
that's great the stress of presidency
already ages by in 10 years and it shows
so so who's in charge if it's not if
it's not Biden who's in charge who's
calling the shots here who's who's at
the desk right now with that button that
could blow the world over 20 times over
it's Ron Clane it's Jake Sullivan it's
definitely not Kamala Victoria Newland
BlackRock and all these other multi
Goldman sacks and all these other
multinational corporations that are
obviously benefiting greatly from the
policies that he's not even putting into
place but he's signing on to and saying
yes I'm for it when in reality I don't
think he's there well getting back to
the actual Gaff people don't they they
don't understand because the White House
is spinning it in a way that they're
like oh well she was on his mind a top
of mind and that's why he said it but of
top of Mind top of Mind of top of mind
he was of top of mind I don't know what
that means like that I don't know I get
what you're trying to say about it when
that phrase comes Steve Portnoy from uh
CBS News I think CBS News CBS News Radio
he said he said look we just want to
understand what happened here like can
we see the prep Were You released the
prepared remarks because it's possible
that you know to be completely objective
here it's very possible that in the
teleprompter it said you know I want to
say thanks to these people that helped
push the bill through
and they didn't put the late Congressman
or the late congresswoman or whatever
and you know like actually just spelling
it out for Biden and he just kind of
I mean just pulled a Joe Biden uh but
she was but the answer was why do you
need to see the prepared remarks we put
the delivered remarks up on our website
so it's it's very possible that somebody
made a mistake in a teleprompter but I
mean ultimately Joe Biden made a mistake
Ron Burgundy he just reads whatever from
the problem but you really need like
that's why I had the card remember the
card that he had where it said walk it
through the door sit down you you know
you do this you do this the reporter did
you see the one with the reporters
pictures and names and news organization
and question and answers that they were
supposed to be given and having the
interaction with all of that yeah and
they give him cards with with little
thumbnails of the people that he's gonna
in huge print with big photos very
simply laid out there you know we we
sometimes do promos for emergency food
here on this on this show and I'm on my
other show and right now I got this big
hurricane barreling down in Florida and
it's it's crazy I mean the uh the water
and the northern part of the hurricane
although all the water was was pushed
out so like the water drains because the
wind is pushing the water and then on
the south end of the hurricane it's it's
actually a a 18-foot storm surge just
flooding Fort Myers is brutal and
stories like that when they come up I'm
like guys you really need to consider
this emergency food yeah because people
are going to get trapped in their homes
for up to 10 days with no electricity
and so have you have you thought about
what your emergency supplies are do you
have canned food do you have supplies do
you have water you're gonna be able to
drink so especially if it floods like
what are you gonna do where are you
gonna go now now that story it's obvious
to most people like why you would need
emergency food but I gotta tell you this
storm
it was a hurricane and our president
doesn't know what's going on no I mean
like Bad Company If the perfect storms
if a commercial came on and they were
like a storm a hurricane could strike at
any moment right now there's a hurricane
buy emergency food I'd be like yeah you
know I get it whatever you show me this
and you're like the president can't
remember if you know that he paid
tribute to a congresswoman who died I'd
be like
oh boy as we're severely escalating
tensions with Russia and trying to of
course make sure that the conflict in
Ukraine is prolonged it's absolutely
Bonkers to to be in this current
situation not just because of the
natural disasters but the human
disasters that are happening in places
like Philadelphia places all throughout
the United States were havoc criminality
and lawlessness is just the new Norm
which is which is again just perplexing
to see such a destruction and such a
chaos within our society and I think a
lot of it is deliberate and speaking of
the hurricane
that story the hurricane is actually
drowning out it's it's
covering up this story like this this is
being pushed back you know I'm just in
all seriousness when the president has
displayed this okay first of all we just
had what a couple days ago where he gets
lost on stage and he's doing the Mr
Burns yeah where he's like walking
around confused and then I was I was I
was covering that and so I looked up the
Cornholio fists remember during the town
hall he's standing there with his fists
clenched like Beavis and with no
explanation everyone's like what's he
doing like something's wrong with this
dude yo
Vladimir Putin is now accusing the U.S I
believe Putin formally I could be wrong
but I believe the US is now being
accused of uh sabotaging the Nord
pipeline Tucker Carlson came out with a
great segment last night wait wait wait
more in depth than the one I put out
pointing out that not only did this leak
occur with two explosions detected on
the Nord pipe North stream pipeline but
the Baltic pipe was just announced the
same day coming from Norway to Poland
right at a very very close to where the
north stream line goes in right so it's
it's like a similar clearly sabotage of
some shape or form greatly benefiting
the west and our president
commander-in-chief this is this is the
brain he has I I gotta say I I think you
know it's it's like a chicken with his
head cut off
that's it well I think the actually the
most concerning thing about this right
here is that this actually there is a
convenient truth there of like why he
messed it up and even in an instance
where there is like a convenient answer
like look yeah you know it was in the it
was in the teleprompter and he kind of
misinterpreted it they still choose to
go with the outlandish lie so it's like
even when there's something there you
just nope we don't know
there were five reporters in uh that got
to ask her that question and she had the
same exact answer every single time and
uh there was there was one I don't know
who it is I'm gonna try and find out but
there was a a female journalist in the
room that actually started uh she raised
her voice and said this happens he's
confused frequently what is happening
here and and she basically just ignored
her and said you know you're you're
being rude you need to like you know
keep your voice down but she has a great
Point people real these Journal analysts
need to actually do their job and say
what exactly is going on we need to see
his full medical record we haven't seen
him take a cognitive test it it's all
ridiculous it's such a double standard
when Trump walks down a ramp slowly they
go oh yeah they they bring in Sanjay
Gupta and go hey doctor hey doctor uh
what what do you think could be wrong
with him could do you think there's
something wrong mentally and physically
when when Joe Biden Falls upstairs three
times they go oh was the wind when he
falls off a bite a standing bicycle
they're like oh it's a stutter he has a
stutter you know so it's it the double
standard is very real but I think you
know he says and they called it a
stutter but I think these journalists
are starting to they're starting to wake
up and they're starting to get really
annoyed with Karine Jean-Pierre who will
not answer a question properly she it's
she she may as well just say like she's
tragically the UN talented here and
here's some real here's what she should
do at this point right let's play again
so so ask me a basic question and I'll
answer it
uh so what is happening with the
response to Hurricane situation so it's
a weight situation kuwaits wait uh well
that's a great question the other day I
was out in New York with a friend of
mine and we went to this really great
place called Lafayette in New York it's
on Lafayette and they have beef tartar
it's amazing it's actually some of the
best so uh next question
so basically what you're saying her
response should be [ __ ] you next
question
oh sorry that's what my bad
okay
answer the question just tell us
something interesting you know like she
could be like
oh yes that's an excellent question did
you guys see the latest uh House of
dragons it was you know I don't
understand what was going on because
like I turned it on and it's the future
now you know did you watch this yeah
they changed the actors but it's the
future now yeah and like renares has a
bunch of kids I just got confused to
what I was watching and turned it off
that's a better answer than anything she
could have said I'd be like oh that's a
lesson solving is that is that what
happened on Australia top of mind off
top of mind I would I would rather
someone be like Karine the president
called out to a deceased member of
Congress can you explain what's going on
I'd be like yeah actually I've been
watching Better Call Saul and I don't
know if you guys saw the episode the
last one where the the German guy gets
executed man what a great show what a
great show you know it was really it was
really crazy to see Mike kind of like
becoming this character where he doesn't
want to kill the person but you know
eventually becomes this cold-blooded
killer and Breaking Bad next question I
kind of disagree with you Andrew I think
she's doing a great job because as a
White House spokesperson she's supposed
to represent the administration and what
better way to do that than to be
confused when she's answering
she's doing it in a very good way and
she she does represent the
administration perfectly what if you're
mentioning how like the journalists are
just like getting fed up with being lied
to What If eventually she just snaps
because like she's desperately trying to
spin the unspinnable and so he just
comes out and she goes I'll be honest
with you I think that dude's bro this
Bane is just gone I don't even know what
to say anymore look I've been trying
really really hard to spin these answers
for you guys but clearly we're at a
point where everybody knows Joe Biden
can't think straight yeah the guy has
two brain aneurysms in 1988 he's not
doing too well what do you think he's
going to be doing
that'd be amazing I would love that what
do you think his brain doesn't work next
question but I don't know I don't know
if if these journalists are being lied
to I just think that she's
she's just not answering a question or
or when the other day you one of the
dumbest things I've ever heard in my
life from anybody in any Administration
Peter Ducey asked her they they were
talking about the Border
um and they were she was like well you
know they just don't they don't walk
just like walk over the Border they
don't walk across the border and he's
like no that's exactly what happens
that's exactly like what world do you
live in I've been there I can confirm
that that's that's exactly dude it's
amazing because she says nothing like
the answers she gives aren't like when
when asked about the deceased member of
Congress she goes well
um and she looks down and she goes um
well uh Joe Biden um was honoring these
people and she was of top of mind
that's what she said she was awesome Jay
Carney for Obama did the same thing even
slower look what I loved about Kaylee
mcinerney was that she had the book and
she'd be like you're lying journalist
but now it's like what's happening is
journalists are actually asking it's
like Peter Ducey I don't know if he like
was a wake-up call to these people but
now they're asking real questions that
that you can't spin it anymore
it's just unspinable I mean the binder
you're you're right Richie the binder
has always been there but it's just so
blatant that she she doesn't have a
thought
on her own a thought of her own she just
has to go to the binder 99 of the time I
just I imagine that like when they were
deciding who's going to replace gen saki
you know they had they had the
candidates and they were like this this
Kareem she can she can string words
together for a long time yeah they don't
mean anything but she's she's really
good at those word salads they shouldn't
it's all word salad it's all it's crazy
they shouldn't she should not she's
there we know why she's there John Kirby
should be there John Kirby
is a he's articulate he actually knows
what he's talking about
he should be there but they went which
Queen Jean-Pierre so she could be like
the first this and the first that and
check off a bunch of boxes I wonder if
you know behind the scenes the White
House they're watching The Press
briefings and they're just laughing at
the journalists they're like they still
show up like at what point
dealing up she's not gonna answer
question she's not even like that's why
I was making the joke about if she just
started talking about breaking bad or
something at least she'd have some
coherent thought like she would be
telling you a thing but okay well it's
unrelated but at least it's something no
she's it's what is of top of mind
she was clearly off top of Mind are you
saying that like he was thinking about
her or something and that's why he
misspoke what does that mean what is
that phrase but she just kept repeating
it and then my favorite is when they're
like okay I'm gonna ask you again
because you'd answer the question it was
I I I already explained it to you I she
was off topic and then she read it again
from the Bible and then and then there
was a a journalist who said well look
you know I think about John Lennon every
day he's on he's on top of mind and I
don't expect him to show up wait a
journalist said that yeah journalists
said that like I'm paraphrasing but but
he said and she's like well when John
Lennon becomes the president then you
know we can talk about it then
comes the president yeah like she's just
an idiot that's like a gen sacky like
you condescend the question yeah without
answering yeah she was so smug but at
least at least she could spin at least
she was competent enough to be smugged
she was the state department spokesman
under Obama I didn't think she was that
I I wasn't really a good man either but
no but I think she would for for the
spin that she spun she spuns spin you
know what I mean like Kareem
jean-pierrez just garbled word salad
it'd be like here let's try it again ask
me a question
you mentioned Jake Harney before uh
there there was a a hullabaloo with Joe
Biden uh when there was like the I think
it was like the bird flu and he was like
wow you know I wouldn't want to get on a
plane because if somebody coughs and
like the whole plane's gonna get get
bird flu and uh and then the Press
actually it was it was actually Jake
Tapper I believe who was like pushing
Jay Carney it's like
um you know that's not true right like
you know the and then they're like well
what the vice president meant to say and
they're like because I don't know what
he meant to say is not what he said you
know like they were trying to spin a
thing that that Joe Biden actually
believed he got a thing wrong and they
were like no what he meant to say it's
like no no it's what he said he was
wrong and he can't admit it but ask him
a question
uh so what did Joe Biden what was Joe
Biden referring to when he was trying to
uh
call out an audience member who's who
died a month ago Volkswagen oatmeal
Ferrari
cumulonimbus oh that's Rhododendron is
correct yeah
um methyl prednisolone oh my yes um that
was a big one Miss Smith
how do you say that
salaciousness no no bismuth salicylic I
don't know you get what I mean though um
Pepto-Bismol
yeah chori queso guacamole languages
yeah and uh graphene bonjourno
like she may as well just be saying
random words and the journalists keep
asking expect it's like they're sticking
their hand in the fire thinking
something different is going to happen
every time
it's like the way you say it not how you
say it it's like if someone says I went
down to Peru and you're like they're
smart
I don't know how to pronounce Peru you
know what's crazy though they really
tried to do a hijab on all the
Republican press secretaries like there
was a scene it was um uh reliable
sources uh they they put out a story
where they said uh Sarah Huckabee
Sanders says you don't get a lot of
answers from not a lot of answers and
and it's her saying it was like a
montage of her saying I don't know which
didn't mean that she didn't know the
answer to the question she was saying
things like I don't know why Democrats
would want this thing and they put and
they and they made because of course
they're dishonest and they put together
this Montage but with with you know Jen
sacky you could do that or Jay Carney
you could do the same you could do the
same thing but actually he didn't have a
lot of answers and neither did jensaki
and oh like I need to remember this I'll
Circle back to you you know how many
Circle backs there were at the beginning
but that's that's why I mean the whole
Daily Briefing is an act in the first
place like the present uh President
Clinton started the daily the White
House briefings and it was basically
like the 24-hour news Cycles came out
they needed stuff coming out of the
White House consistently content and it
became like I started working at NBC in
2000 and uh end of 2012. and I decided
to leave the cable news game because I
was like this is such BS because it's
you pay you pay your dues you ask the
right questions and if you ask the right
questions you play the game for long
enough then you'll you'll be one of
those front men right so you just have
to play the game
in cohorts with the White House and so
it's like this relationship between the
fourth estate and the government that is
the exact opposite of the purpose of the
press which is like to you know ask the
tough question I think they should just
get rid of it it's it's TV time
for oh yes reporters that's all it is
because they have a press offer office
yeah they should do a tick tock briefing
there is such thing as email they can
just go and say Here's my question
please answer it in an email but instead
they're you know I mean if I don't watch
this stuff I've never I watched every
single day
it's you may as well just sit in front
sit in your bathroom and flush the
toilet every few seconds that's what
you're watching that's what I watch yeah
but it depends on like what's Kimberly
mcaninny she actually answers hold on
but she was calling out the corporate
press that was awesome I mean she she
didn't have to do that but she didn't
she did it very well she was amazing and
and uh Sanders was great too she they
they were they were very very amazing
press secretaries Sean Spicer on the
other hand total garbage he he said he
set the tone I pitched him on a
motorized Podium after uh Jenny McCarthy
what's her name remember um silent live
did that spoof and he they had who was
what was his name yeah Melissa McCarthy
she was on a motorized Podium it was
super slow and I was like a sash on
Spicer I was like hey man I want to give
you a motorized Podium that's so fast I
have a skateboard that goes 25. we'll
put flames on it and we'll rip that
Podium around DC and it'll go viral how
awesome you didn't like my idea how
awesome would it be if Dave Smith
actually wins the presidency and then
Michael Mouse becomes the press
secretary
that it'd just be
it'd be so amazing
he'd just be like for one he'd be
ragging on the corporate price would be
hilarious but then he'd probably just
say things exactly as they are I think
it would just be an empty room after
like two weeks just no one would go
anymore why because they just be getting
wrecked and they're like no no I think
now let's just ruined myself someone
would ask like what's going on with the
withdrawal of troops from Syria and the
Middle East and it'd be like there's no
reason for us to be at war in the Middle
East
like Dave Smith would be like running
the wars we're getting everybody out of
here this is a waste of our time and
money and then you there's been there'd
be no spin they'd be like yeah we're
ending the Foreign Wars like we promised
if then Lockheed Martin would call up
NBC and be like yo you guys can't send
in a reporter there anymore
can you imagine it would be an empty
room but let's think about that with all
of those clips where it's like brought
to you by Pfizer brought to you what do
you think the media would do with like a
president Dave Smith you got president
Dave Smith vice president majesture with
him with a Michael Mouse press secretary
they would the news would be the the
most insane thing ever there would be
like photoshopped images of Michael
Mouse kicking puppies like Lockheed
would be like shut him down like I don't
care like it would just be just be the
craziest news you'd ever you could
imagine if you thought it was bad with
Trump imagine actually getting some
Libertarians in who are like yeah we're
gonna shut down the military industrial
complex yeah they wouldn't get that
that's the point is like they wouldn't
let it happen well and for that matter
think about the news cycle if they
actually became competitive
right now among Millennials
overwhelmingly they reject both parties
most like younger people are more okay
with Republicans I'll put this way
younger people that lean conservative or
libertarian are more okay with the
Republican party than young people are
with the Democratic party young leftists
learning individuals despise Democrats
it's like 35 of them of Millennials in
gen Z think the Democratic party is
trash but they are leftists they are
left-leaning or liberal so it's possible
that you'll get eventually a third party
that actually breaks through I don't
know about winning the presidency but I
just imagine if there's a real risk one
of one of the fears among Democrats is
the libertarian party actually pulls
votes from the Democratic party not the
Republican they thought that um
they thought the libertarian party was
going to hurt the Republican party but I
think what happened in 2016 is it
actually hurt Democrats it pulls their
votes so they would have no choice but
to try and destroy the libertarian
candidates because it's bad for them for
the establishment I think that'd be
that'd be that'd be interesting to see
what are they going to do about it huh
it could be a Pfizer party a Pfizer
party yeah they'd probably win the
Pfizer I mean yeah if if uh if
corporations are people my friend yeah
exactly then why couldn't a corporation
run for office well now we have the fun
people speaking on behalf of
Corporations but pretending they're
still people
yeah but that's what our White House
Press Secretary is doing right now I
don't know if I don't know Evolution to
all the political BS that's going on I
feel like
it's just gotten to the point where the
emperor has no clothes even the
journalists now can't pretend otherwise
and there's no there's no solution
there's no like moment where people all
agree like hey this this probably isn't
working let's get like some competent
people in here no it's just like I won't
let you win so I'll do whatever it takes
even if it means putting Biden in office
I don't know I think that there is
some kind of change that will happen
from this like if you looked at the last
major populist election or major
populist I guess uprising
You could argue that there are a couple
more in between but William Jennings
Bryan in 1896 gave that famous speech
the cross of gold and he wanted to
switch the silver standard which would
help small businesses and farmers and
William Jennings Brian's was like 36
years old went into the DNC gave this
amazing speech total Dark Horse
candidate uh took the presidential
candidacy ended up losing
but both political parties changed
majorly in the wake of that and actually
the Bull Moose Party Teddy Roosevelt
that was kind of the aftermath of both
parties that's when the Democratic party
really switched from the party of the
South to the starting towards the
working class part of the working class
which you know FDR's party I mean racist
around then for a couple decades yeah
look I'm not here to defend the
Democratic party of 1896 I'm just saying
that the of 1890s the shift the shift
started when this Dark Horse came out of
nowhere and gave this amazing speech
about how he's going to help out the
little guy and even though he didn't win
he came close and it forced both parties
to reckon with the fact that they
weren't acknowledging that aspect of the
population so I don't know I want a good
thing I want to talk about this story
here let's talk about Jordan Peterson oh
by the way rule of thumb
yeah real quick it was William
Blackstone 1723
uh it was
that was the basis of U.S common law
which came from English common law which
was the rule of thumb but he didn't
explicitly State the thumb law in the
United States so he but he's talking
about beating your wife and how to do it
let's follow this story let's talk about
the good doctor Jordan Peterson The
Daily Mail says controversial Jordan
Peterson tears up as he agrees he's a
hero to incel men and responds to Olivia
Wilde calling him an insane pseudoel
intellectual saying it really didn't
bother me this is a great story it's an
important story uh Jordan Peterson makes
a really good point when he says uh oh
so he's asked by Piers Morgan you know
are you a hero to incel man he says okay
why not and then he actually starts
crying which you know I I he cries a lot
he's a very empathic person and I think
that he he knows he's a hero to incel
men because he's like these men have no
one else saying this to them well that's
gotta strike a chord with him this is
what he says he says something's the
effect of you know it's interesting how
there are men who don't know what to do
they're lonely and unsuccessful and
they're and they're trying to figure out
how to improve and they're just attacked
and insulted and you you get these you
know insults against them he said I
thought the marginalized were supposed
to have a voice instead you people like
Olivia Wilde saying she made a movie
based on him in in what way is Jordan
Peterson in any way insane you know it's
just like
they just hate anyone who I I suppose
it's you know I gotta be honest I really
don't understand why they hate Jordan
Peterson so much but I have to assume
that it's because he's empowering up to
the individual yes I think so I was
actually thinking about this earlier
today because I was listening to a remix
of his spoken word as I sometimes do
because what he has to say is
interesting and wise and I was thinking
I think that they hate him because
they're evil and he's trying to
construct people and they only know how
to destroy people and they're doing that
with him just like they've done with
lonely men over the past few years that
was what I came up with I I'm I'm
gravitating toward the idea that they
truly are evil because it seems I think
it's their source of their identity
comes from this you know culture war
that they perceive Jordan Peterson to be
the enemy and because maybe I don't know
they didn't have a loving family or
something like that that they have to
cling to the tribe of uh me too you know
and that it they'll just continue with
that regardless of how much it's
grounded well just to add to this point
I think they also prop themselves up by
stepping on other people I think that's
the norm and this is why Jordan Peterson
is is such a horrible person to them
because he's like hey don't get stepped
on hey hey stand up for yourself you're
a human being have some dignity have
some respect for yourself and it
counters the agenda which is going along
with the destruction of the modern man
have a dirty room have a dirty room
don't be organized don't have your stuff
together because that's bad for business
because when you're disorganized when
you're disheveled when you don't have
family when you're mentally and
physically weak you're you're the
perfect consumer and I think that's
exactly what they're after they want you
to be a consumer it's bad for business
when people stand up for themselves when
they have families when they're healthy
when they're happy and this is why
Jordan Peterson trying to help people is
not along with the agenda we have to
stop Jordan Peterson because Jordan
Peterson is stopping our agenda is it is
is there truth to this claim when like
you see women like Olivia Wilde saying
the stuff that they have bad
relationship with their fathers yes 100
because
maybe it's because
a relationship with my dad and I still
consider myself really lucky for that
but I see that a lot of people I think I
there's nothing else you can conclude I
think that's what they're missing what
do you think Richie
well I think I I have a personal
connection with Jordan Peterson because
when my dad was sick I started listening
to his Old Testament lectures yeah and
that was really right when he was coming
into the public sphere and I think
that's part of it too is there's a
religious component there which is one
of the reasons why Jordan Peterson is is
threatening because he's articulating
all of these kind of old biblical ideas
in a modern context and it resonates
with people and it's people see a
Resurgence of the religious right which
you know growing up I didn't I didn't
understand the power of it until I was
confronted with
something as difficult as you know like
a tragedy in your family but I think
that that's really what it is is Jordan
Peterson actually has a point and that's
that's scary to people who like things
the way they are where they have power
they want in cells they want white
supremacists so when Jordan Peterson
comes out and says identarianism is bad
and don't be an Intel improve your life
they're like uh oh he's damaging our
access to a boogeyman you know the
immediate desperately desperately tries
to come out claiming everyone's a white
supremacist or a white nationalist Vox
has that famous article where it's like
what was it like 11 million people have
white supremacist views or some other
ridiculous nonsense and then John
Peterson comes out and he's like hey
don't have these views don't be a
collectivist pick up the heaviest thing
you can find and carry it work on
yourself clean your room all of these
things are going to turn these in cells
into functioning members of society it's
going to give them strength and these
woke people are terrified of it
it's one of the main things standing in
there uh in their way of full Conquest
the full control of of humanity is the
subjugation of the Modern Men and I do
believe they were successful especially
when you look at testosterone levels
sperm levels mental health physical
health it's all declining along with IQ
so so there is something else going on
here and seeing this kind of concerted
attack against individuals who are there
to predominantly help people should be
concerning for the average viewer should
be concerning for anyone watching this
because we are seeing the destruction of
the modern man I don't think that's a
crazy statement to assert here uh
because the results are clear especially
in our current political and societal
system uh you can't ignore it so I think
we do need help but but no one's helping
them and the only person who is is
getting uh is getting attacked how does
that make sense
by the way I I actually just looked it
up to make sure
from what I recalled but I did a
freelance gig in DC with a guy named uh
Andrew cochburn and there was a photo of
Olivia Wilde and I looked it up to
that's right that's her name yeah so
that I met Olivia Wilde's dad and answer
Olivia's question and he's a journalist
and I don't I don't really I didn't
glean much from the interview itself
because I was just you know setting up
cameras and it was an interview but he
seemed to be a nice guy
um well but I don't know if you know she
could just be pandering right Olivia
Wilde is like hey yeah exactly exactly
but people often say like when you see
these feminists these women on Twitter
it's like they had a bad relationship
with their father I'm wondering is that
just a meme or does that come from
somewhere is that true that women with
bad relationships tend to lash out in
this way well so as far as I can tell
it's not feminists typically that are
accused of having daddy issues it's
women who are on places like only fans
who are seeking the approval of men
actively over the top being hoes
honestly I think it's just we have a
culture like you said of the story
Rachel dolezal has an only fans oh gosh
I saw that oh well there's also only
there's also a lot of concerning stats
when it comes to single parent
households and households where the
father is not there especially when it
comes to criminality especially when it
comes to people's overall life
expectancy their happiness their health
a lot of is correlated with how they're
brought up and if they're not brought up
with a strong family unit the individual
does suffer the child does suffer not
just mentally but also physically so I
think those stats can't be ignored
Jordan Peterson talks about them a lot
and talks about the importance of a
family unit and I think this is also
again one of the reasons why they're
like hey he's bad yeah he basically
sticks his thumb in the entire
post-modern world order which is like
this this idea that everybody had of you
know we don't need all that stuff you
don't need to have this nuclear family
and a white picket fence in a car in
order to be happy and he says no I mean
that's what you're saying it's like
there's an agenda that's been around for
40 years and he's just calling it all
out very effectively I feel feel like
someone's feelings or expressed feelings
about someone like Jordan Peterson is a
good indicator of whether or not they're
a sentient being or an NPC I'm being
somewhat facetious but what I mean is
a rational person will say either I'm
not familiar I I've heard about Jordan
Peterson but I've not listened to him
before so I have no real strong opinions
or they'll say something rational like
you know I've listened to him I'm not a
big fan of some of the points he made
about religion I don't agree with or
they'll say I'm a big fan of the things
he said because
you know they said otherwise any one of
those responses indicates a thinking
person who's like you know let me try
and figure this out but the people who
are like he's an incel hero evil
alt-right whatever they clearly haven't
done any groundwork to understanding or
listening to anything that he has to say
so if you're trying to figure out if
someone is a Discerning individual or
let's just say an NPC in the in the
colloquial sense you can ask them about
Jordan Peterson Trump's too overt you
know everybody knows Trump he's up there
he's big there's always something to say
about him but these people I bet if you
went to Olivia Wilde and said really so
what don't what don't you like about
Jordan Peterson what do you think makes
him insane she would have no answer at
all she doesn't know because he's he's
famous enough but he's still obscure
enough where
with like my point is Trump's in the
news you can easily have remembered
something he said and then been like I
don't like how he handled this thing and
then you're like okay with Jordan
Peterson they're gonna have no nothing
because they don't actually listen to
anything he's ever said
yeah they're terrified of being canceled
you know that's everybody's that's the
culture that we live in today which is
everything that happens is Forever on
the internet and if you say one wrong
thing then your whole life is going to
be over and nobody wants to say that one
wrong thing because
I don't know that's that's the world we
live in where critical thinking isn't
valued over you're not supposed to think
you're supposed to react you're supposed
to have emotions you're supposed to of
course just go along with the group
think go along with the herb herd do
what you're told and and essentially
people thinking for themselves that's
extremely dangerous for a system that
thrives off of ignorance and there's a
lot of ignorance I think there's no
denying that I mean just she just
reminds me of like when you go to a
college and you interview the students
outside and say why are you protesting
Michael Knowles oh because he's a Nazi
well what did he say what was what was
the thing he said well I heard you know
well I you know again I know like she
didn't really write this script or
anything
she I I do believe that you know I think
you guys are right that she's just
pandering and I mean the stories the
story's about like a cult leader you
know in in like a town it's not like
that
it doesn't really have anything to do
with
Jordan Peterson is not a cult leader by
any means you know he's just like a an
intellectual a self-help he's trying to
help people do you have a Ukrainian flag
in your bio because if you don't I'm
coming for you all right well hold on
guys we got breaking news
uh rapper Coolio's passed away of
cardiac arrest oh no he was at a a
friend's house and he went to the
bathroom and then he didn't come back
from the bathroom and went inside found
him on the floor he had a cardiac arrest
I guess a heart attack damn 59 years old
he's in Gangster's Paradise now
he's pulling out for Coolio man can I
where can I pork can I pour a little of
this in the garbage I guess I guess is
that is that beer yeah yeah that's part
of pouring one out it can't be like all
right here you go soda there we go I
poured it out a little bit out so uh
it's 59 I mean that's that's kind of
young isn't it it's young for a heart
attack is that is it it depends on his
was he doing a bunch of hard drugs
that's what the first thing I want to
know is that I don't know
had he in the past right you know left
him with a weakened heart or something
yeah that sucks
yeah man just hearing a lot of these you
guys hear about the surfer he was 24
years old and he had a stroke while
surfing what and then died oh my God
yeah it was like a 24 year old like they
said it was like a prodigy Surfer yep
what the heck and and falls over like
while surfing and then drowns and then
they were like he had a stroke while he
was surfing
he's crazy man crazy stuff you know and
Surfers are like the most you know
cardiovascularly fit people yeah that
you'll meet well I think you know just
we're seeing a a lot of people a lot of
stories I'm popping about people
suddenly dying and stuff and you know
it's just it reminds you of the the
nature of reality that uh you know life
is fleeting I mean you're not allowed to
ask any questions little kids okay this
program is brought to you by fazer well
here's a big barbecue was a big barbecue
guy Coolio was yeah uh like he he used
to do like uh guest you know uh pit
appearances you know like uh maybe it
was cholesterol that killed him you
don't know don't I don't know by the way
I think it was a lot of propaganda with
cholesterol out there I want to say
Kalani Rob but um
I'm trying to remember that I'm trying
to remember the surfer's name it was
Kalani something
I can't remember his last name the guy
who died there was uh the viral video
about a little girl who got myocarditis
it was an ad for uh was it like was it
New York Presbyterian or hospital or
something like that and this little
girl's like I got the worst stomach ache
ever and it turned out I had myocarditis
so the doctors gave me medicine and it
just it's just you know like you got to
pay attention to stuff because you know
we weren't talking about children
getting myocarditis a few years ago and
now it's it's become this you know
enough to wear that the hospitals are
doing commercials for it and a lot of
people that we we feel maybe be a little
bit too younger having heart attacks or
dying in their sleep so it's just
something that we should pay attention
to that life is fleeting and uh you know
it's just it shows a show that in the
past few years we've really come to
understand the importance of talking
about mortality because we clearly were
ignoring these stories only a few years
ago you know only a few years ago we
weren't talking about the kids getting
myocarditis and no yeah you know for
whatever reason you know yeah it's as if
there was some kind of intervention that
happened that that you know people had
to partake in that they were extorted
and and manipulate I don't know about
any of that look I'm just saying like
I'm just saying no I'm just speculating
here I'm not saying don't say that thing
that rhymes with schmental either okay
don't don't bring that up oh yeah I have
no idea I have no idea
look is it is it maybe it's unfair to
accuse me of having done drugs maybe
it's not musicians and and you know rock
stars he had you know big hit in the 90s
maybe his lifestyle yeah high risk man
you know maybe that was about all about
and you know and maybe it's climate
change yeah right yeah sure I was about
to say that yeah took the words out of
my mouth if only those damn Republicans
funded climate change you know Coolio
would still be alive sad really well now
uh oh actually let's let's do this let's
pull up this uh do I have this story let
me see if I if I still have it I might I
might not have it here we go here we go
we got the story here from CBS Don Lemon
tries to pin hurricane Ian on climate
change without evidence oh that's that's
an excellent headline from a CBS Outlet
like Siri
yeah well of course of course so let me
let me uh let me play this clip because
it's it's it's so can you tell us what
this is and what effect because of the
change has on this phenomenon
we can come back and talk about climate
change at a later time I want to focus
on the here and now we think the rapid
intensification is probably almost done
there could be a little bit more
intensification as it's still over the
warm Waters of the uh Eastern Gulf of
Mexico but I don't think we're going to
get any more rapid intensification if
you look here you can actually see
pretty interesting for your viewers you
can actually see a second eyewall
forming around the inner eye wall and
that's basically the second I will all
have overtaken the original firewall and
that should arrest development uh so
listen I just I'm just trying to get
that you said you want to talk about
climate change but what what effect does
climate change have on this phenomenon
that that is happening now because it
seems these storms are intensifying
that's the question I don't think you
can link climate change to any one event
on the whole on the cumulative a climate
change may be making storms worse but to
link it to any one event
um I would caution against them okay
well they listen I grew up there and
these storms are intensifying something
is causing you to intensify so this
storm is just it's a massive one it's a
fact trust the science they said as Don
Lemon goes I'm talking to a scientist
but I have personal anecdotal experience
and I think the storms are worse how
does that fit into my talking point I
have a talking point in which you're
saying doesn't fit with it so can you
take what you're saying and fit it into
my script that I wrote for you what do
you recommend another scientist to speak
to because uh I'm not trusting you he's
like that guy's never coming back on
everyone I mean Don lemon's not really
known for his uh intelligence he he he
prophesized and theorized how a black
hole swallowed the Malaysian airplane
just a few years ago so so we're not
expecting much from him I'm not at least
that was funny when he did that and the
lady
I made a little video about it years ago
he's talking to this woman and he's like
you know a lot of people online are
saying that the plane may have been
swallowed by a black hole and I know
it's Preposterous but is it Preposterous
Mary and the moon goes or your rear your
plane is a small black hole would
swallow the whole universe gosh she
actually says a small black hole would
swallow the whole universe and it's just
like lady there's like a billion black
holes or whatever like that we can see
no but Snopes did a fact check on that
and it's actually it's true that small
black hole would actually yes no well
Snopes did a fact check so there's a
super massive black hole at the center
of the Milky Way galaxy as far as we as
we believe and uh Universe still exists
so you know whatever but that's Don
Lemon and then when I when I brought
that up I've had people defend them over
that and they're like well you know he's
just trying to do a show and I'm like
what yo if I get a couple of Stoners and
sit him down and they're sitting there
with big bicycle you know big twirly
mustaches being like dude what if a
black hole ate a plane I'd be like all
right this is a good show let's order
some pizzas get some sodas and just let
it roll because this is funny but when
CNN the most trusted name in news is is
doing things like that I gotta say you
know like you know maybe your brand
ain't all what a crap was it what it's
cracked up to be this clip is amazing
because what did he try three times he's
like how does climate change play Royals
uh it doesn't and he goes well you know
but climate change and he's like no no
climate change well I live there so
climate change yeah I don't I don't
wanna I don't want to know about I don't
want to know about the hurricane I want
to know
why hurricanes are getting you know
bigger because of climate change why
can't you answer my question do we have
issues like this you know I know that
the liberal left Democrat types like
it's like fascism white supremacy
climate change they can easily just
shout anything like you know young kids
are getting sick and having heart
attacks must be climate change no no
doubt no I'm not kidding there were
articles talking about how there's an
increase in like heart attacks or
cardiac events and they're like we think
climate change is causing it and I'm
like whatever boss do we have anything
like that can I be like Don Lemon asking
this question as communism can I just
accuse everything everything's communism
yeah but at the and at the same time uh
remember the story it wasn't even a
direct Trump quote but there was a story
that Trump asked why we couldn't nuke a
hurricane like a hurricane and and
people got upset with him like oh my God
why would he do that it's like because
he wants to stop a hurricane I mean it's
not it's not like a nefarious thing it's
not like the the new nuclear bomb is
going to make the hurricane stronger you
know it's like he's trying to stop her
haven't you seen what is it the core
have you seen the core with uh Hillary I
watch a lot of questions
so they go down to the Center of the
Earth and then they have to detonate a
bunch of nukes in succession well so I
guess the plan was to drop a bunch of
nukes and then blow them all up so it
starts the course thing again like okay
hold on the core of the earth stops
spinning so like makes sense yeah the
planet's being destroyed because there's
no magnetosphere or whatever so they
have to like drill to the Center of the
Earth and then they like they find that
the mantle is actually Hollow or
something I know there's dinosaurs or
whatever there's no dinosaurs I'm
kidding but anyway they get to the core
and then they're like you know Land of
the Lost but anyway they get to the core
and they're like we gotta detonate these
nukes and then it will start the spin
again and keep the core going which will
generate the magnetic sphere whatever
and magnetosphere and then they find out
that they actually miscalculated this
the size they didn't realize the Earth
was Hollow so they don't have enough
nuclear power in the in the WarHeads to
actually you know spin the core so what
they do is they deploy them in
succession so it creates a ripple effect
so it goes one two three instead of all
at once and that's so so maybe maybe
Trump was not wrong you know a single
nuke won't do it but 12 nukes could one
two three four and then it stops the
spin from happening it's like 12 nukes
could save one human life then it's
right they did the same thing when he
asked if uh we could drone strike uh the
cartels
and everyone was like what an idiot he
is asking if we can drone it's like well
we I mean I mean weddings in the Middle
East and
these guys are making drugs that are
killing our citizens and we can drone
strike a wedding in the Middle East
everyone will be silent but you know you
want to kill cartel members I think the
reality is that like if we nuke the
hurricane all that would do is make a
radioactive hurricane and it would be
like blowing radioactive particles
everywhere and it would just be that
much worse no I think they could deserve
that though for sure I think the media
would come out and go why would he want
to do that to that poor hurricane why
they would just spin it to say like you
know he's racist against hurricanes or
something oh yeah they'd be like is it a
natural phenomenon he clearly hates the
environment he just wants his mother
yeah
[Laughter]
he's sexist against Mother Nature well
Tim ruined my night because now I have
to go home and watch the core oh no no
you don't yes I do now I do yes I do and
who else is in it is it's Hillary
it's an All-Star cast yeah and some I
think somebody died in a two like they
stayed down in Decor while yeah I can't
remember you know did Bruce Willis have
to stay back to save the world no no
that was the other one that was
Armageddon yeah but then there's also
wasn't there another movie that was
basically the same as the core because
they did Armageddon oh no it was Deep
Impact but that's the same time it came
out as defense was the same as
Armageddon yes oh you're saying there's
another core yeah and I have to watch
both of them well yeah you can't watch
arm again without watching Deep Impact
uh Bruce Greenwood who uh he was like
the captain in Star Trek oh uh the Star
Trek movies yeah Stanley Tucci uh
sacrifices at least those were original
ideas in Hollywood you know like they're
like paramounts coming out with one
about the core now so we got to come out
with one yeah what's up with that at
least it was like original ideas now
it's just like they're remaking remakes
because the other Studios remaking the
other reason yo how many Spiderman
Spidermans do we have how many Godzillas
have there been like Godzilla remakes
it's ridiculous well cultural stagnation
man but at least Spider-Man and that's
She-Hulk She-Hulk though oh oh that's
phenomenal
beautifully it's a series oh but it
feels like it but it feels like a film I
must have only watched the first episode
no no no no look I'm a huge MCU fan I'm
a big fan of the MCU and She-Hulk is
some of the worst you just not being an
NPC ever seen I've ever seen look the i
i praised the first couple episodes like
that's entertaining like she's fighting
with the Hulk and they're talking about
superheroes and stuff the show now is
trying to be a lawyer comedy written by
people who know anything about lawyers
and it's just really really bad the last
episode was so bad that I was just
clicking skip everything I'd like I'd
click 10 second jump and then they'd be
nonsense in 10 seconds nonsense 10
seconds nonsense and then I was like
okay there was no episode here I'll tell
you when I like the show starts and she
and she looks at the camera and she goes
yes this episode is a self-contained
wedding episode and I was like okay next
it is some of the worst programs and I
have to watch both core movies and the
entire season of She-Hulk because the
worse it is the more I have to watch it
oh it's it's so bad oh man and they're
dangling Daredevil in front of everybody
to convince people to watch it that's
the only thing they got oh Daredevil oh
because he's a lawyer because right and
he's going to be in like episode eight
or something don't you ever like
watching like a 200 million dollar piece
of hot garbage though and you're like
wow here's what we're done
movie and it's about a guy uh named
Andrew who can uh has the powers of an
alpaca oh yeah it's alpaca Powers sure
and and it's going to be good because
you think about Spider-Man and it's like
one of the hottest Marvel properties and
it's the stupidest concept for a
superhero like if you if you were like
it's a guy who can throw uh he can
freeze things like okay it's a guy who
can throw Fireballs like I get it it's a
guy who is spider he can climb walls and
stuff I'd be like
well okay I guess so you know we grew up
with it so we think it's normal I think
that if I make alpaca man and you know
he's really strong and he's hairy and
you know he's like Sasquatch or
something and he makes sweaters from his
sheddings right well you know maybe but
like he spits on people I think can we
uh can we have a wolverine Cameo too can
we do that any and Wolverine's cheering
him as I could be polite with this thing
sweaters out of his hands all right okay
one of my idea how about we do a better
one it's a guy and he uh he he can uh no
I like the alpaca thing I'm taking it
uh here's what I'm saying I couldn't
make I could make alpaca man and with
good story writing it would work and it
would be an original idea we're
culturally stagnant we've got 87
Spider-Man movies 87 Marvel movies and
now like the whole MCU is just vomiting
up old stories from the 50s 60s 70s or
just regurgitating all the same
characters again and again and again
it's like someone just makes something
new just
She-Hulk She-Hulk is not new Shield is
from the 70s you want to know why did
you not know that but but She-Hulk
hasn't been a property like yes it has
property there's multiple Comics there's
there's television show arcs bro
She-Hulk is a long Horseman on TV yes
really She-Hulk is a character that's
appeared on numerous shows in the Marvel
Universe I did not know that yes well
like into Comics obviously but on
cartoons I think she was in the X-Men
Saturday morning cartoon in the 90s and
stuff like that she She-Hulk is a
character that's been around for a long
time for decades and they're just saying
like let's pull up the old library of
things that have been made 50 60 years
ago and redo it and I'm just like bro I
would rather watch a guy who looks like
an alpaca fighting crime it's because
China is the biggest market for
Hollywood now and you know that like
Transformers Newton seven just goes off
the
charts because Fast and the Furious is
relatively a relatively new cultural
phenomenon I love fast The Fast and the
Furious universe is is the greatest
Cinematic Universe and you know they
went to outer space in the last time I
talked about this all the time in F9
they go to outer space in Hobbs and Shaw
they got a super soldier cybernetically
enhanced I'm saying an F10 I want to see
superpowers or maybe Mech suits
I saw a comedian I saw a comedian on
Tick Tock uh talk about uh he was like I
was watching one of the Fast and Furious
movies and and uh they introduced
Ludacris's character and he you know he
has a garage and then he had his side
hustle is that you know he organizes
these races right and then he goes I
hadn't really seen everything in the
series and I go to like I skipped like
to episode 9 or 10 and there's
ludicrousies like I'm hacking into the
Pentagon like where how did where did
that Arc come from like he was a guy in
a garage you know where the ark it all
changed I think it was Fast Five when
they're taking the plane off the The
Runway and it's like a 30-minute scene
and it takes 30 minutes for the plane to
take off and you're just like okay the
suspension of disbelief is like this has
been 30 minutes that they've been on
this Runway I mean it makes no sense
these movies are they're so over the top
and so ridiculous but there's this
there's just something about them that
that make them entertainers for F10 they
have Mech suits and ludicrous is like
you know Dom is like we got a problem
you know my brother is joined up with my
other brother and my sister and now
they're taking over the world and he's
like I don't know how we stop him and
Lucas is like I got you and he builds a
mech suit like an Iron Man suit and then
Dom is like he can fly and he's like you
know and then they all get Mexican suits
and then what happens is for f11 you
know he's wearing the new experimental
armor from ludicrous and while he's
fighting a group of terrorists there's
damage to the fusion core which which
blows up causing a chain reaction and
all the suits erupt but the energy from
the core gives them all superpowers and
now you know now he can actually he can
just run faster than his Dodge Charger
yeah now he's got super speed so it's
like you want to race and then he's like
gotta go fast and then what we do is we
started we start with the mouse button
yeah we gotta get Disney to buy
Universal so we can introduce them into
the MCU and then we'll have an original
new thing over okay how about this
we just start making movies that don't
suck we're doing it
I'm waiting I'm waiting for I'm waiting
for a trans Hulk okay that's good it's
gonna come and then the next few years
and there's going to be microaggressions
and they're gonna Hulk out and it's
gonna be awesome to see and I'm and I'm
waiting for that movie did you just miss
trigger me
let's let's put this story here talking
about culture we got this from Indy wire
it's weirdly hard to read stranger
things Star what's his name Caleb yeah
Caleb it's cut off by the thing
McLaughlin calls out fan racism why am I
the least favorite you feel the bigotry
McLaughlin said sometimes it's hard to
talk about and for people to understand
but when I was younger it definitely
affected me a lot first I want to point
out here's what he said he said why am I
the least favorite have the least amount
of followers he says a part of a deep
conversation I'm on the same show as
everybody from season one
so like the dude
has less followers than his Co co-stars
so he immediately sues his face people
don't like him because he's black
now in that capacity right there I saw
this story and a lot of other people saw
the story and they started saying like
oh this is wokeness this is a problem
and then I read further and I realized
he is 100 correct I believe the reason
he has less followers is because many
fans of the show are in fact racist and
he hit the nail on that with the hammer
and you know what you want to know what
what's missing from the context in this
conversation he says sometimes overseas
you feel the racism you feel the bigotry
sometimes it's hard to talk about and
for people to understand but when I was
younger it definitely affected me a lot
that's right outside of the United
States there's probably a lot of people
who won't follow them because they are
racist you take a look at what happened
with Star Wars in China and they took
the dude who played Finn off the cover
where they shrink him or something or
put him in a helmet they put him in a
helmet they put him in a helmet because
they were like people in China are very
very racist and they don't want to see
this and so the Disney as a corporation
was like yeah we're totally fine with
that that to me is insane but this
dude's seemingly not talking about
people in America he's saying like I got
less followers than them yeah it's
probably people in China and other
countries that would watch stranger
things but are racist
so there you go man you know Amman is uh
um Instagram page right now it doesn't
look like he he posts a lot and he
already as of now has 15.4 million
followers why does he have more
followers than me it's because people
stress people
possible explanation
God that's it I can't believe only 15
million people would follow him that's
15.4 unreal yes on Instagram he's one of
the most famous people in the world and
he's like he's like when people overseas
don't like me as much as my other cast
members and he's not that actor what a
victim like he he posted on July 30th
September 9th isn't that September 12th
September 16th September 18th and that's
it all the posts wait did he maybe he
deleted some or something so this is
inadvertently making the case that
America is in fact the greatest country
on Earth more enlightened exactly but
that's why people don't want you to like
real so if you're saying that America is
an inherently racist country can you
find me one that isn't exactly good
question
well if America is the least racist
country but it is racist then every
country is substantially worse and more
racist there you go
uh bingo you got it that's that's it but
you're not allowed to say that so this
show is shut down and
that'll be it you know America is a
great place yeah that's why everybody
desperately wants to be here correct and
then you know what's funny is we're
seeing these videos there's a video that
went viral that uh Jack besobic was
sharing about this like white woman and
she's like hi everybody I moved down to
Guatemala to be part of sustainable
living community and then she's like
spinning and like there's like there's
an active volcano and then I saw that
and I was like is this why woke people
don't like white people because they
thought like it's it's a really annoying
thing to have these like hippie man bun
you know uh like
elitists be like I'm gonna move down to
Guatemala to teach the poor people and
it's just like yeah is that what you
were talking about because that because
I gotta I gotta agree that is annoying
for these people to do but it's funny
because you have white people leaving
the US going to Mexico and going to
Central America at the same time you
have people from Central America trying
to come to the United States so as you
just you know it's kind of funny how
that works huh
you know I I just can't stop thinking
about this this kid he wants to be a
victim so bad he's a millionaire
he's on a hit series
15.4 million people follow them and yet
he's he's like it's not enough like he
he you really need to I mean you know
it's it's a it's a quote from an article
you know maybe there's more to this kid
but you know Caleb if you're listening
just
appreciate what you have you know and
don't don't get caught up in the numbers
yeah don't get caught up in what you
don't have and and how other people
think about you appreciate the fact that
15.4 million kids uh like you and love
you and that you're a millionaire and
you're probably set for life that you
could reach out to and have a positive
impact on by promoting personal
responsibility good values good morals
and you could lead as an example of
something good rather than of course
just concentrating on something that
that is negative and and I think there
is an aspect of society promoting
victimization uh promoting as you
mentioned Andrew this larger idea hey
I'm the victim here and now you have to
really like my stuff on social media and
the algorithms promote that stuff and I
think it's it's disgusting I think it
should be pushed back on because in in
reality like we're some of the most
privileged one of the richest people on
the face of the world just by simply
living here in the United States we're
so freaking not just than human history
yeah yeah in human history so freaking
lucky everything at our fingertips and
if you want something go out there and
get it there shouldn't be anything
standing in your way but that's hard I
just looked up
I looked at the network of this the cast
of stranger things the first thing I
want to say is these like celebrity net
worth websites are just very wrong like
oh yeah of course one of them said like
Ian was worth like five million dollars
or whatever and we were all kind of like
10 million but whatever but no we were
kind of like maybe there's something
we're not graphing he's got those yeah I
mean he's a co-founder of mines and
mines is worth a lot so like maybe it
wasn't wrong but I'm like I'm pretty
sure this stuff's not true but anyway it
says that Caleb McLaughlin's net worth
is four million dollars and there's
um there's another person let me let me
pull this back up whose net worth is
only one million dollars I think it's
one I think is it is it Maya are all
those like AI generated websites that
are no this is a different one this is
Netflix life okay but it did look at
those websites and then compile them but
uh let's see Joe here is 4 million
Charlie Heaton's five million I mean
okay here you you go Sadie's sink is
worth a million bucks but she's new
right she's new yeah but so so anyway my
point is
I don't know what their net worth
actually is but I'm pretty sure everyone
on this show is a millionaire and so
there is something special about a group
of millionaires and the not even the
lowest millionaires complaining about
not having enough and there's just
something where it's like
I don't I don't know how I'm supposed to
feel about that you know what I mean
like it's a big group of ultra rich
people on a very successful and popular
show and one dude's like I'm the least
favorite it's not okay and it's like
well you're still like literally in the
top thousand richest people on the
planet or something like that I mean how
many millions
there shouldn't even be a news story
it's like oh well people overseas don't
like me so much okay and that's it like
wow but he he does mention that people
wouldn't get in line for him at
Comic-Con some people didn't stand in my
line because I was black some people
told me I don't want to be in your line
because you are mean to 11. how does
this happen right I mean like no I mean
this for real like did somebody come to
him and tell him that just like say
racist things to him
they wouldn't get in like I mean what's
what's the proof oh but I mean it makes
tons of sense somebody gets in line they
wait for 20 minutes and they get up to
him and say he's gonna let you know like
me and my friends you know didn't want
to get in line because of your race
right do you remember that BYU story
from a couple weeks ago no we're talking
about player yeah yeah and it was like
that got a ton of clicks and then the
you know the real story
is like that nobody wants to hear that
so I think that's the point is like Hey
how do you you know keep yourself
relevant how do you get in the headlines
well just why don't you go say something
controversial that's going to get both
sides to click on these websites and to
talk about you and follow you on social
media yeah and this worked they were
like yeah oh yo he's gonna absolutely
get sympathy subscribers you know it's
like oh you know I really like him and I
should have probably followed him I
don't want to be a racist so I'm gonna
like I'm gonna like click follow on this
guy uh but he's he's like a b-list actor
he's not like he I mean when you compare
him to Finn wolfhard or Millie Bobby
Brown I mean they're like the the
breakout stars of that show he's not and
and it's maybe it's because of his
character the way it's written or
whatever but it's like if you go to
Comic-Con like there's not a lot of time
you have to you have to look at the list
and see the agenda like who's gonna be
there and you kind of map out and go
okay I really want to meet this person I
want to meet this person and he wouldn't
like if I was a kid if I was a stranger
fan I I don't know if he'd be in my top
20 honestly here's what I'll say about
stranger things though mad respect for
something original yeah it is original
they're still there from the Montauk
project no I know but
he's right Richie is absolutely right
people right the Montauk project was
written what like 93 or something let me
see on this this one yeah let me see it
let's see what's the Year this is I
think the second one was written
somewhere in there 89 or something it
was 92. 92 I was close I was close and
again
I'm I have nothing against this kid I
don't know anything about his personal
life but you know he's he's not one of
the breakout stars of the show the
Montauk project is fake news you know
and it's made to look real and it's very
it's very clever and very well done but
my understanding is it's a total fiction
and I did a bunch of research into it a
while I'm gonna have to have a debate on
this sometimes it looks like a Mark Dice
book so I did a bunch of I did a bunch
of research into it and it's like
considered to be the the the story
behind it is that they wanted to make a
book that overlapped with reality and it
would sell better and be marketed as
something real but it was just like a
function who Preston Nichols I don't
know I don't know that's what I read but
uh so maybe it's not true maybe maybe
it's all right you can watch interviews
with this guy Preston Nichols I mean
he's he's a Nutty dude but he definitely
knows like radios and frequencies and
all that stuff and when he talks about
how he participated in this project what
do you like cross diagrams and like my
point is stranger things is inspired by
the Montauk project but it's like an
original concept with like characters
and you know the upside down the the
reality I I appreciate it man yeah I
agree I think the show's bad you know
the last season was just miserably
terrible but I like it because they're
doing something new you know like what
do we got now we got a prequel of Game
of Thrones a prequel of Lord of the
Rings we get more Marvel derivative
garbage and it's just like okay
what you know when it all started it
went because I think 1997 was Seven
Years in Tibet and they banned that
movie from China and I think it was MGM
that produced it that lost hundreds of
millions of dollars and after that it
was like a message to Hollywood like yo
our Market's huge and it better appeal
to us as well as the American audience
as well as you know so now it's a global
market that you're that you're but that
was going for so that's an argument for
making new things not for regurgitating
no because it has to be homogenized to
the point where you know it's going to
work across a broad population which
makes sense that you could write
something new to work across because
then you don't know how it's going to do
you're like Transformers 67 the great so
let's just do 68 and 16. of course but
that's not that's not let's put a
Chinese actress in there to appeal to
China so we can get like that like how
do the Chinese feel about this new idea
they're like
Shang Chi was very obviously like they
were trying to break into the Chinese
market because the movie had no reason
to be in San Francisco at all did you
guys see it I don't watch Chinese it
whatever
it's like all of Hollywood though yeah
exactly but it was like you wonder why
it is this guy was in San Francisco at
all it's like the story is very much
centered around China and then the main
character is like I'm in San Francisco
now for some reason and now we're going
back to China and they go to like portal
to another reality with like you know
pandas or something
and then there's like that's what they
did with Doctor Strange too right they
changed the Tibetan character yeah that
was so this is really funny I know you
have to watch the core and yeah I do so
so before I got a lot of work cut out
yeah so there's this meme going around
because of the aerial thing where they
made the Aerials portrayed by a black
actress
and so they uh there's a meme where it's
a bunch of non-white characters that
were played by white actors and they
were like no one cared no one cared no
one cared and then it shows the the
screaming woe Jack when it shows Ariel
and they're like the meme basically says
like nobody cares when white actors play
characters of color and it showed the
ancient one in the comic Tibetan guy and
then it showed uh till the Swinton and
then I had to tell people like whenever
I see the meme I'm like actually the
fans were really upset that they got a
white woman to play that because the
reason they got rid of the ancient one
was not because of racism was because
they were trying to appease China and
China didn't want a Tibetan guy and so
everyone everyone else is like there you
go oh that actually makes sense why like
okay so what you mean the fans really
were mad about that yeah like but like
while you're explaining that they tuned
into like the next Tick Tock video and
they're like wait what'd you say sorry I
didn't hear that and then they started
doing a weird name dance and then in
China they'd ban that stuff but they
always complain about uh like oh you
know
for they always say that all people are
racist if you you know you gender swap
or if you uh race swapping nobody cares
like Sam Jackson as Nick Fury where was
the outrage there well Robert Downey Jr
dude Robert Downey Jr
he's still he's he's not a fury in the
comics he did uh was made black a long
time Tropic Thunder but he but he was
white originally and I think and the
same thing with the the Fantastic Four I
hear that they're that they're looking
to possibly make it an all-black cast
when uh when the last Fantastic Four
they had
I just walked out Johnny Johnny Storm
with Michael B Jordan right but but I
think the uh the latest news on
Fantastic Fours they're going to get
um uh what's her name Daddario and her
brother Alexandra Daddario is that her
name but I don't know whatever but her
and her brother are going to play Susan
storm that's what that's what the rumor
is so you know whatever uh what's that
guy's name John Krasinski he's yeah okay
I think he did he did he did great as
read Richards but I guess they're not
going to use him I don't know I kind of
feel like it looks great it it he looks
he looks like I know Reed Richards but
he's a he's a good character anyway he's
a good actor but I I gotta be honest I
think the MCU is just completely done
it's just become regurgitated derivative
garbage at this point it had something
unique when they were like re
reinvigorating these stories like Iron
Man and Captain America and Thor I think
end game was the end game I think after
that it's just been like
like black widow is awful oh yeah I mean
it was there's uh I can't remember who
did it I'm really sorry but there was
there's there's like a it feels like
it's a five hour breakdown of this movie
showing every tiny little thing that's
wrong with it and it's it's Brian I
can't remember who did it uh but I
watched the the last Spider-Man movie
and I've kind of given up like I didn't
I didn't think about uh watching Thor I
didn't watch Doctor Strange I'm sorry I
was never gonna watch She-Hulk uh well
they're not telling Original Stories
they're not
here's I like doctor strange it's a
movie it's an origin story it's a guy's
doing his thing sure Doctor Strange
Doctor Strange two is Avengers
like Thor Avengers it's all just
Avengers now it's all like here's 27
characters all dancing on stage it's
just more of a video game than a movie
like how much of that movie is CGI
versus like you look at the budget and
then you look at the credits and there's
like 20 actors and like 600 animators
and the only reason I would actually
watch it is because it's Sam Raimi
directing but that's it we gotta go to
super chats because we're way behind so
if you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends however Tim
gets to come become a member we have an
uncensored show coming up through at 11
p.m don't want to miss it's gonna be a
whole lot of fun let's read super chats
faster faster all right Jack Attack says
the hurricane is worse than I thought
it's knocked out the power grid in Cuba
thousands are without power in Florida
but worse than that the waffle houses
have closed it's nice
cereal now everybody's like to move to
Florida too that's when you know it's
serious and then I'm like
yeah okay maybe you know
Raymond g Stanley Jr says broken brain
Biden totally unawares broken Bane
broken broken brain button fell up the
stairs all the king's horses and all the
king's men couldn't put Biden's broken
brain back together again
actually that one's kind of sad when you
hear it like that yeah there you go
how is nobody asking about Luke's cans
what what are you talking about oh yeah
CB Robertson says enjoyed the debate
about hatred on Monday I wrote a book
called in defense of hatred what people
who reject hatred fail to realize that
there is no love whether the possibility
of hatred oxytocin is tied with both
very interesting passion passion
deserto says little hand says it's time
to rock and roll
Brandon hamster does Luke out of breast
reduction that was a Point Break quote
now I can finally pay attention to what
Tim is saying
oh okay yes Daniel Cavin says glad to
see the inflation reduction act worked
on Luke
yeah really
not Bob Saget says please book Alex
Jones and Immortal Technique together on
the same show would go down as a top
three show of all time it would be a
great debate I think they already
interviewed each other uh and they they
argue oh well they come from different
perspectives
um but they had a cordial sit down in a
conversation that it was very
interesting between the two and I held
the rally with some of my friends in
2006 and it was me Immortal Technique
Alex Jones and the makers of loose
change we were all as the fifth
anniversary at Ground Zero together and
we held an event that raised money for 9
11 First Responders so shouts out to
Immortal Technique he always did a lot
of Grassroots work helping a lot of uh
people who needed a lot of help he's
helping a lot a lot of people now check
out a lot of his projects that he's
doing and I think he would be great for
the show and it would it might even be a
debate which would be interesting Boris
cafiovich says Lydia's expression at
Luke's quote clapping butt cheeks
comments
every penny of the Super Chat I didn't
notice that unnecessary
by the way that quote that was just read
from Point Break is actually the quote
that's on the back of my shoes
little hand says oh is that what is it's
like little hands is time to rock and
roll yeah well there you go Richie's
movie
why does it say 2018 yeah we do a
different one every year with a
different quote Pina Shea's helicopter
tour says Tim the words you're looking
for is demoralization lizzo mocking the
flute is just part of what Yuri besman
have warned us about this was purposeful
no someone someone also said it's defile
uh no no defile
yeah yeah was was maybe better
um I don't know if I think
demoralization is the bigger picture you
know taking uh items significant to your
country's history and then bring up on
stage as a spectacle and an
entertainment show where it's just like
it diminishes it you know
yeah demoralization
cheeseburger says it's over folks those
who wanted to fix it are demoralized
while the rest of our brothers and
sisters are all cheering as the train
approaches the cliff hmm I don't know
about that do you feel demoralized
no nope I feel I feel uplifted yeah
exactly yeah I don't feel demoralized I
feel like all of this stuff is actually
lighting a fire of passion yes exactly
yeah so just go down in a hell of a
gunfire and but I won't be demoralized
you know what I'm saying yeah like uh I
feel like a lot of what we're seeing is
it's not like I used to when a younger
I'd say like don't bother voting stuff
like that like who cares but now I'm
like everyone you got to get out you got
to vote this is you know so I'm I'm more
passionate about the stuff than ever Eve
24.
2024 you voted for Kanye yes I did I'm
going I'm I'm thinking about it you're
on defense he has a he has a good couple
good uh policy positions I'm considering
so BP 23 says James Madison owned slaves
he was a slave owner right yet she was
so honored to play his flute seems odd
congrats lizzo you played the same notes
he played to his slaves shaking my head
I'd assume he probably was but maybe not
someone want to fact check that I like
that story I think we go with it I like
that but they would argue that she's
appropriate she's taken it from him yeah
she's taken it back yeah yeah
well there you go she also she also you
know people there's people are saying
two things they're saying she played the
flute she didn't really she like tooted
the flute and then gave it back some
people are saying she doesn't know how
to play flute actually she's apparently
she's like a trainer she does yeah she's
a flout did you say flautist yeah yeah
yeah it's the loudest yeah I was I I
think she's a floutist in that the way
she flouts them cheeks but you know I
guess there's two different definitions
yes Viola says I asked my parents if
things have ever been this bad and they
said never they're both 84 years old
that's what I'm saying man so does that
mean they lived through World War II
because if so that's a little concerning
yeah that's uh that is concern yeah but
we're talking about in the United States
with like conflict you know people
obviously in the Civil War would be like
oh I remember what you know but those
people aren't alive anymore so
although it'll be really interesting in
the future when people are gonna it's
gonna be like 21 63 and they're gonna be
like
man it's so bad in this in in this
country like has it ever been this bad
let's pull up the old pop podcast
archives from Tim cast IRL and figure it
out yeah we're just basically a time
capsule for for everything it's like you
become a prophet like 100 years now it's
like he was saying that the Civil War
was coming
I finally came and there was a small
band of Tim casters that were prepared
but here's what would be funnier if it's
like 100 years in the future and they're
like in his old age the crackpot was
still adamant the Civil War which never
did come up and it's a clip of me going
oh you're coming how do you know and
it's just like this ratty old Hut with
like their beanies got like six holes in
it
and then someone walks in like okay
Grandpa time take your medicine and I'm
like oh I like my medicine like Grandpa
there's no more cameras around them been
there for 40 years
well how would they how would they would
they school children they took away your
show when you when you said that joke
about Pfizer well it's like the you know
the the Tim cast hologram or whatever it
is in the future like what what whatever
uh you're like Tupac yeah oh man because
I didn't still doing shows Wikipedia is
saying he's not around us actually yeah
Wikipedia is saying James Madison had a
population of over 100 slaves yeah he
did own slaves that's a lot yeah sure
did that's a lot in Virginia I just
gotta say like if there's one thing that
ever made me think it's not a good idea
to be a public figure is that they're
going to turn you into an AI creepo
robot in the future they're going to
three they're gonna they're gonna create
Android bodies they're gonna create an
AI of you from all of your social media
they're then they're gonna put it in the
robot and then there's gonna be a weird
facsimile of you walking around and it's
just so creepy do you think it's me
weird like if you know
kids will basically be able to know
exactly who their grandparents Grand
great-grandparents were like there's all
these you know but it's not just that
it's that like when you think of your
grandparents you think of old people and
then you see these old photos of them
when they were younger like wow what's
going to happen now is it's even it's
even happening right now it's crazy to
like
looking at a celebrity today who's maybe
like 50 years old
and sing with a movie and then being
like you know 20 years ago I didn't
watch their films and going back and
seeing them as a young person it's like
this is with high definition footage and
and and and cell phones it's becoming
more and more ubiquitous here's where
we're headed though they're already
talking about taking your your social
your Facebook and using all the
information about you to create an AI
that can simulate who you were answer
questions even about what you thought
what you felt they can then put that
into a robot body and so your
grandchildren like you're dead and your
30 year old grandchild is like you know
my grandpa passed away a few years ago
so we built a 24 year old version
compiled his Facebook from when he was
24 to create his 24 year old Persona and
then here's a robot of him and here's a
robot and then all of a sudden this
robot it's not really you there's no
soul but to other people they see you
going like where am I I was I was just
in in Harper's Ferry what's going on
it's like a grandfather I'm your
grandchild like whoa and then it's like
this weird robot versions of you and it
could be like any they could they could
take they can say how old do you want
your grandfather to be oh let's do a 35
then they grab your social media profile
from 35 and younger and they take all
that data into an AI and say there well
let's make him 40. okay we'll grab five
more years throw it in the mix that's
how crazy it's gonna be
and I do have a fact check for you uh
lizzo actually did play a little song on
the flute oh she did she didn't just
toot it I thought she tooted it and then
handed it back she's wearing a different
black shirt and black pants that's when
she does twerk while she's playing this
flute
we played the video of her twerking and
then yelling I just twerked no it wasn't
that yeah so she played the video of her
doing it they hand her the crystal flute
she toots it but there was another video
of her
was it in concert
it was at the National Archives
she's twerking and playing this
historical flute and I'm just grossed
out yeah I I I liken it too it's not
just an action figure action figures
have value to people but this is a
historical artifact that she basically
ripped out of the packaging and yeah now
it's no longer been the pristine Crystal
artifact it's this this is like taking
the Betsy Ross flag and doing a strip
tease with it well she played the flute
I don't like the stage performance
things I think that was like the
twerking stuff but she actually twerked
again at the thing yeah she twerked
International okay National Archives
classy classy woman okay what if like
the lead what if you know Anthony Kiedis
went up there and played the flute what
do you think the reaction would have
been I mean my my attitude is the same I
don't care like it's it's
I I'm not a fan I I I think it's
disrespect that's just me man I I you'll
notice this too for people who know me I
have a bunch of artifacts I've got a
Civil War rifle it's an actual Union
rifled musket it's it's real oh you're
you're telling me you like art you've
showed me every sweet sword in here and
I'm I'm I love those things yeah but you
know so across the room I have a union
so I bought an antique shop I have a
collection that I recently acquired of
Life magazine going back I have the
first magazine the first edition of Life
magazine uh official officially that was
published it used to be uh life used to
be they reformatted it was purchased and
they turned it into life and I went to a
few antique stores I found hundreds of
them and it's amazing to be able to read
what people thought or were being told a
month before D-Day because you know what
they were saying the US has sent
armaments to the UK as a defensive
measure
oh really is that what they did well now
we know the truth so reading that
perspective of what they actually
thought of time why they how why did
they vote who they vote for it's amazing
it's amazing so I I go to antique stores
I'm like this is incredible it's like
pres preserving the ideas the memories
in the context of the past for me to see
like if somebody
tore a page out of an old book from the
1800s to use as a Kleenex I'd be pissed
off yeah if somebody was using an old
book from the 1800s as a window stopper
I'd be pissed off to see somebody
anybody be handed a flute that's never
been played before owned by the fourth
president and be like twerk with it baby
like even if it was some other rock star
or some other famous person or Kenny G
whoever I'd be like dude it's like
watching it's it's worse than someone
tearing open you know an original Star
Wars action figure like that's just some
cultural item this is actually in the
presidential archives of the history of
this country yeah it's our Collective
but outside this this flute doesn't have
anything with our culture it was we
didn't even know about it that's what
I'm talking about okay but she played
the flute if she just played the flute
and didn't work and maybe
but a flute's meant to be played right
so uh no I have a a rifled musket that's
never been fired before if someone were
to fire that it would ruin it
it'd be ruined this is no one's ever
even dry fired this it came out of an
Armory it was produced for the union it
was never used never given to anyone
eventually someone went in and they just
dispersed these people started
collecting these items and they were
handed off and this one found its way to
an antique shop and it's got the
certification and all that jazz no one's
ever dry fired it that would that would
that would alter it right now if you
want to see
just to the best of our of of of our
understanding what this thing looked
like and how it responded before it's
even been fired once it's here
if someone were to load it and fire it
now it's got damage to it now it's got
residue and placed in it and it's and
it's not even from the same era it's
just like dude I think I I don't know
man that's just me that's just me you're
right it's it's I mean that's what's
happening with all the founding fathers
is that the reverence that we had for
them is now being not only called into
question but thrown right into the
garbage so I think you're right that it
is kind of a meme for what's actually
happening across our culture i just I
just I just really love uh like mementos
and Relics and curios and things like
that when I whenever I would cover a
news story I would always take a piece
of that story back with me so I have uh
I don't know where they are but I had
fragments of the Lenin statue they were
just bits on the ground of marble that
were [ __ ] from the shattered ground and
I had like two little pieces I think
they're gone I don't know where they are
but I have um I have police tape from
when the two officers were executed by
the black nationalists in Brooklyn that
happened on the street where I lived so
I walked outside my house and I saw the
police tape ripped from when they closed
it off 10 feet from my house so I went
up and I took a piece of it and I said
this is from that moment I have the
newspaper from when Darren Wilson was
acquitted leading to the riots in
Ferguson I have an armband from the Thai
uh uh protests I collect these things
because they're representations of the
thing that happened of a piece of
History so that's just me I collected
Riot Munitions yeah I've got I've got
from France I've got you know shells I
keep all those things they they're proof
that something happened that's not a
story it's it's this thing exists
because because of this moment in
history but I I and I I agree I agree
exactly what you said with the with the
rifle and I agree with with those things
that are are part of a moment in time I
just don't think that the flute
rep what does the flute represent like
what moment in time it was probably just
a gift and it's like here you go Mr
President and he never played it exactly
that right but but you know somebody's
blowing air into a flute I don't I don't
think is is I think it's very different
than than uh taking a rifle that that
says pristine is that one and shooting
around I like I understand what you're
saying I get that and I agree with that
there was once a fluke that had never
been played it no longer exists it's
gone
and and I think that's a bad thing but I
don't think it was destroyed there's
nothing the flu the idea of the pristine
Crystal flute has been destroyed yes
it's gone
such an item no longer exists there is
no longer an unplayed flute that was
owned by James Madison now there is a
flute that was played by lizzo who
twerked with it okay and again if she
didn't work if if she just went in and
played it it's like the Yo-Yo Ma
equivalent I I I assume you just can't
understand and I mean no no I do
understand I'm saying
ideas exist
an object exists what is the object that
is defined as an unplayed Crystal flute
owned by the fourth President of the
United States that is gone now now what
remains is a crystal flute that was
played by lizzo on stage who twerked
that was previously owned by James
Madison it was taken from the Library of
Congress and given to her on stage where
she joked about twerking with it and
it's just like
there is no longer an unplayed flute you
know what I mean that it's gone right
there you go all right let's read some
more Daniel Turka says how about we make
a movie parodying the life of Olivia
Wilde while she's satirizing the life of
Jordan Peterson was it a satire when she
was making a comedy about Jordan
Peterson is that what it was it's hard
for me to tell you wasn't it really bad
like sometimes I watched it was like the
number one movie this last week this
last weekend it was I heard it got
panned by the left uh it did it it
wasn't like super critically acclaimed I
think it has like a 60 something on
Metacritic but it it was the number one
I watched the movies with the lowest
million the lowest critic rating but the
highest disparity between what the
critics think and what the hell audience
thinks but you know she doesn't have any
moral High Ground to stand on anyway I
mean you know with the whole thing with
uh leaving Jason Sudeikis for Harry
Styles you know like that that whole
thing so screw what she thinks honestly
all right Cornelius butt knuckle says
Nick ricada hit the nail in the head
with hit the nail and head when he
pointed out that the She-Hulk show is
actually is exactly what you'd expect
from a Marvel show if it was written by
a bunch of early to mid 30s wine moms
there was a story that the pop culture
crisis crew was talking about
um who was it from Charlie's Angels
someone oh yeah we just talked about
that today yeah there was a thanks she
was she regretted that it was marketed
to only towards the girls or whatever
and I just gotta I just gotta wonder
about this
do women
feel inspired or powerful watching women
fight hunt box kill maim and things like
that
like on average I know some women do but
I'm wondering like it Charlie said just
bombed I'm I understand it did it did
and that's what she was saying like well
they only Market it towards the girls
but didn't she say something like it's
four girls don't watch it or whatever
she literally said if you're a white
male don't watch my movie it isn't for
you and then she turned around and said
why aren't white men watching my movie
they're all just sexist but I'm
wondering if there's a thing where it's
like men on average are like I like the
adventure and the conflict and women on
average are like I like the social
interactions and this and the personal
development also aren't those
characteristics that you're describing
what would also describe toxic
masculinity well I suppose to a certain
degree but it depends if if it's like a
firefighter you know saving a bag of
puppies that's not toxic masculinity
masculinity would be no he man explains
to the puppies as he's bringing him down
yeah yeah but I'm just saying like I
feel like what they're doing is they're
saying
there's they're they're like we should
make movies for women so let's take mail
tropes and make it women but now it's
like do women like watching women box
other women no guys would they guys
would that's exactly the problem they're
trying to make their female characters
into second-rate it's like if the
notebook you just flip the two rolls
around
you know yeah Ryan Gosling is like
sitting at home waiting oh right The
Notebook goes to war and you know the
first chart the first two Charlie's
Angels movies made money they were hits
and I I actually saw both of those
movies in the theater you know no right
but that was like Foxy boxing basically
you know no I mean it was there were
there were there were fun kind of goofy
movies and Drew Barrymore and you know
it's but this new one I had no interest
in watching because I don't like Kristen
Stewart you know it's like I didn't want
to watch her for two hours you know like
and oh and then Elizabeth Banks movie I
probably didn't I probably didn't see it
because it was she directed it you know
well I mean you're not allowed really to
say that because you know you're a man I
mean yeah and you're you're taking a
movie with women in it and that's a
man's plane so you know loud
I just I just any time that it's
something about you know like New Wave
feminism I just go
got it but the Charlie's Angels movies
were fun though there's no winning here
no
no that's I agree that the original
Charlie's Angels were great they they
were under and it's not that the women
were like there was an inherent like I
guess feminine that they were still
embodying which I think women like to
see like there were being women in
stilettos and like kicking the crap out
of dudes and it was the tone like the
tone of the movie so there was it was
actiony but it was like a little over
the top and corny and funny yeah you
know it was self-aware yeah exactly yeah
this new one was like very serious
wasn't it yeah it's like She-Hulk
explaining you know to he Hulk
oh man you know what I'm I'm watching
Better Call Saul
it is one of the most satisfying shows
I've ever watched I was complaining
about Star Wars recently how it's like
Obi-Wan Kenobi walks out of the ship in
Revenge of the Sith and he's like Anakin
in the past two hours I've gone from
loving you to wanting to kill you and
it's just like
why like why did Anakin go from like we
have to stop Palpatine as a Sith too now
I'm his servant and then like what have
I done I know just like just like that
all of a sudden I was really annoyed
because I was like the shift from him
being a Jedi to him being Darth Vader
was just like a coin flipped because
he's literally like Master Windu
Palpatine's the Sith Lord we must stop
him and he's like okay wait here and he
goes no I'm coming with and then all of
a sudden he regrets what he did what
have I done I'll be evil in Murder kids
I was just like what but Better Call
Saul better call Saul's transition from
Jimmy McGill into Saul Goodman yeah you
can you can see it it's so well done
what's really really impressive about it
for I'm sure many people have already
seen it because I'm on season five right
now what what's so well done is the the
dynamic between Jimmy and Kim who's like
a significant other for those who don't
know
I see these interactions where he's
becoming more con artisty and more like
Saul but then his interaction with Kim
is very like
well written and normal like when she
gets upset with him he apologizes
because they're actually in a
relationship and he's like okay yeah I'm
sorry like you know we'll talk about it
but you can see they're still being
pulled apart whereas like with Star Wars
it's like you're my brother Anakin now
die like what
yeah I mean you're what you're saying is
it was uh poorly written is that I'm
just saying Better Call Saul I'm just
continually impressed with
it's I'm just look when I complain about
writing and stuff Better Call Saul is is
better than I could possibly ever
imagine the Howard Hamlin the the like
the lawyer from the other company
he's such a well-rounded character it's
like he comes off as smart me sometimes
but then he gets emotional and and like
you understand who he is as a character
it's such a it's an amazing show I'm
really impressed I think did you watch
Mad Men no is that also good
yeah I'll check it out I just characters
well you know I watched breaking bad I
thought it was pretty good I like
cigarettes
let's read one more it's very important
Scott Jeffer says what's your thoughts
on Deadpool 3 and the few teasers I'm
very excited for it it's going to be
silly fun around Ryan Reynolds is great
and the teasers they did bringing back
Hugh Jackman he's gonna be Wolverine
it's gonna be funny and I'm gonna have a
fun time so that's cool yeah they
released a new teaser today if you if
yeah yeah where they're sitting together
it was good the first one where he's
like I have nothing I got nothing
hey you and then and he walks past
meeting Apple okay and he's like you
want to play Wolverine against yeah sure
Ryan and that's it he walks up the
stairs that was really really good I
smuggled a bunch of beers into the
theater when I saw it with my mom the
original Deadpool and she's like what
are you doing there's eight beers why
would you bring eight beers in the
theater I was like Mom you don't
understand what this movie is going to
be and she literally is tapped me on the
shoulder like give me another one I'm
like eat a beer this you're drinking all
the beers now see so all right everybody
if you haven't already smash that like
button would you kindly smash that like
She-Hulk smash Shield smash subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com we have a members only
uncensored show coming up for you at 11
PM you don't want to miss it follow the
show at timcast style you can follow me
at timcast Richie do you want to shout
anything out uh you can shout out my own
name Richie McGinnis r i c h i e m c g i
n n i s s and where people could find
you that's right there just type that in
anything it's all up there refugee
also my sub stack uh again Florida you
know stay safe my friends uh and and
Beyond Florida too uh you can find me at
don't walk run uh on Twitter and you can
find me at don't walk around Productions
on YouTube and again thanks to everyone
for having me and uh nice seeing you
again Richie it's great seeing this
Refugee from Florida are you still stuck
here because I don't think they're
reopening the airports yeah no uh and
and trains too they're not they're like
you know stick around man okay we'll get
you on the mini ramp we'll film we'll
film it'll be fine I can uh I got I got
some good uh I got I got a fun little
video of Richie uh skating so maybe I'll
yeah maybe I'll replace it later if that
doesn't count if I if I get a certain
amount of of new uh followers on Twitter
no I'm kidding all right but uh thank
you guys for for having me and I I love
you all uh especially Luke and his uh I
do like that can I squeeze him real
quick hey hey this is a family-friendly
show here
you know I know it would be distracting
hey guys it's a pleasure being a part of
the Luke cast cans
um
the Bill Gates moves are back
Libby Evans
beer
lukemilkers.com backed by popular demand
thank you so much for having me
lukemilkers.com that's a website it's
official it's real see you there thanks
so much for having me I am constantly
upstage by Luke everything damn right it
gets worse I can't stand it just kidding
it's good times
um I do have to say that I just saw an
Instagram video from our good pal Adam
Johnson and he is recreating that Meme
of Florida man out there in the store
with that American flag and a beer in
one hand and I just stay safe down there
y'all it's crazy times
um you guys can follow me on
twitterminds.com
at Sarah patch Lids as well as Sarah
patch let's stop me worth the follow we
will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys